Sure.
Boom.
And we're live fight companion.
Motherfucking Bravo,
Brandon,
mother fucking sharp.
We're here.
Fight Companion Darren till versus Donald Cowboy Cerrone is the main event and
Ebi tomorrow.
Uh,
Eddie Bravo,
invitational Jujitsu tournament tomorrow.
Is that at the Orpheum again at the Orpheum downtown La.
You can get tickets@ebiofficial.com.
You can watch it on UFC fight pass.
And you also have a choice now to watch it on paper view@inchbyinch.tv.
That's cool.
That's a great,
it's a good move.
So if you don't have fight pass you can still get it.
Yup.
That's my company.
But if you don't have five paths,
you usually get bypass.
Bypass is the shit.
And we're watching this fight on fight pass right now.
And I'm not just saying five passes a shit cause I mean UFC employee,
if you're a fan of the sport,
there's fucking everything on fight pass.
You will go down a God damn rabbit hole.
Pride fights for thing.
If we could watch so many fights.
And there's also like a bunch of like organizations that you never heard of
before that have awesome fights,
height and just the fact,
just the fact that you could watch any of,
see if I ever just,
that alone is worth it.
It's amazing live just that alone.
Just boom.
You could just remember that fight.
Boom.
You could watch it.
Remember that five boom,
you could watch them.
Demand demands and the pride fights.
Fights.
That's what I like.
That alone.
It doesn't even need anything else.
We should do some,
uh,
fight companions for old pride fights.
The Best Lens Electron,
Cro,
cop versus a fade or Vandelay nog versus fate or,
yes.
PSAP.
Nogueira you know,
come on.
[inaudible] question is how long after UFC do they put the individual fights on
bypass?
That's a good question.
And you were saying too,
they upload them.
Yeah.
There's a lot of people on this before we,
we can see this fight on fight pass.
Well this class,
this is on fight pass right now.
I mean archived.
Oh,
there'll be I crop right afterwards.
How long does it take?
100% it's right afterwards.
Uploads right away.
I don't think so because I've tried to check fights out.
That just happened.
Maybe they were Fox fights.
If it's FX or f or Fox sports one or Fox sports two.
They own those.
True or Fox.
They can't put those on bypass.
I don't know,
but I don't think so.
I think you're right.
Joe Fox.
Yeah,
I think they do.
That's part of the,
the sun.
You don't pay all that money on clothes or money.
They don't want to pay fuckloads of money.
So you could just not have Fox and just watch it on fight pass.
But the one,
I mean they should own it.
I mean,
they're paying for,
what are they doing with it?
They ain't doing shit.
They replay them all the time.
Again,
like replaced one last night was Cain Valasquez risk,
big foot.
And I watched that.
Damn,
they're starting and replay them on Fox and tonight I have it on my DVR.
So,
uh,
not because of my GPO or I'm a hipster Olin because business,
I'm too busy to too lazy
to turn on the TV.
UFC fight night.
On the DVR,
like automatically set to record and it always is recording old fights,
always school ones constantly.
So anything that has been on fight at on fs one or any fox venue,
bro.
I have fs,
one fox spike Bella tour.
I have fucking access TV fights on that bitch.
Yeah.
Amen.
So oxy,
yeah,
I love access TV.
I love of lion fight.
Yes.
Fight fighters.
They got some fucking amazing Moitai of some PVC box and on there and shit.
I've everything.
So these dudes who are fighting right now,
p p p Chada and Wilson,
um,
I'm assuming patrol does the guy in the red and yeah,
the little thing on the bottom that Wilson dude has a sick left kick man.
He's thrown,
thrown some nasty,
a hard left kicks to the body.
But I don't know these dudes,
I heard there was some good fights on the prelims are above.
I heard was good.
You know who won that?
Jamie,
do you guys know?
No.
Who did he fight?
I don't know,
but got head kicked.
Rm did and then I'm not sure,
but Connor was there and he was trying to corner him and the ref had to stop the
fight.
Andre Fili.
Why him?
Why did the ref,
I have to stop because Connor was an official corner man and was yelling out
instructions and the ref was like,
hold up,
you got to chill man.
Be Professional and kind of was like my bad.
My bad.
Really?
Yeah.
You can't yell out when from your outside of the cage.
Well,
he was cage side and he walked up to the cage and was yelling instructions.
Oh,
homeboy was like,
Yo,
you're not an official corner me and you'll get three.
Not For let's,
it's a title fight.
So he was too close.
I'm just,
it was a distraction and he's like,
you gotta chill man.
That's a good rule.
There really is a great rule.
Yeah.
You can't have crowds of dudes that are your friends yelling,
calling you a faggot.
There you go.
Yeah,
look at him because he made,
he just shows up everywhere with cuff links and a beautiful suit.
He just walking around like he owns the place.
He does well cause he does.
He puts his hands at me.
So it's Mark God or to mark is a motherfucker.
It is a motherfucker.
He's not taking any bullshit.
Oh,
this dude's got the choke standing rear naked.
So I watched Bella tour last night.
Right?
That a,
what is that dude?
That Gracie dude,
uh,
halls son hall a son.
Do you know?
Uh,
uh,
I am in Gracie.
Yes.
Bad motherfucker.
That motherfucker serious to just some dudes out.
How about that?
No.
Yeah,
seven.
I know.
Seven submissions.
He's a,
he's a,
he's a bad motherfucker.
Submissions.
Neiman Gracie.
And who's his father?
Hall's holes.
How do you say it?
Holes.
The holes.
The dining it.
Yes.
Hang Glider accident.
Yeah.
Dude,
you should have seen this neck crank Eddie.
I thought he's gonna bake this motherfucker's neck.
Yeah,
the dude looked every bit of 44 but I guess he's only 32 minutes.
Great.
Here.
Like the guy who fought.
Yeah,
it looks like Luke Thomas.
But look right here.
Yeah,
he,
he was young son,
but he had gray hair.
But if you take away the gray hair,
I can't take ripped and look good.
For sure.
Defense to men.
He had him on his back the whole first round and it fought him off.
But then,
um,
Neiman's switched to a net crank.
It just,
it looked like it hurts so bad.
Are you going to lunch in and we sent this.
Oh yeah,
there it is right there.
No,
that's not it.
That was his fight at mass square garden.
He won that one choke to last night.
He had the dude's neck side.
It hurts so bad.
Musashi did look great Brock.
So to sync this up,
we're at 25 seconds.
The first round,
23,
2121 and uh,
put Pete Chota.
I don't know how to say his name is on the back of Wilson.
He's getting worked.
Oh Shit.
He's got the choke.
Uh Oh shit.
Oh Shit.
I said no,
no,
not much time.
Not much time.
I think you can hang on.
It's tucked under the chin.
Oh,
hang on.
Powerful.
He's going to hang on is out.
He's good dad.
That's the bell.
But last night and belt,
where was Saucy d look,
lethargic,
kind of take off.
I had to go to the comedy store.
I missed it.
He definitely won the first round.
But then,
uh,
show Manco shut a,
yeah,
it's a tough one.
No.
What is his name?
What's his name?
She'll minko right.
Sly Manco Manco
he hit him with a,
uh,
overhand left and closed up his ride.
I like his whole ride.
I kind of like Etsy and then the sec,
I thought she'll make a one the second round and the third.
But the gift of [inaudible] Resource,
he did not look like a world beater.
No Shit.
No.
Interesting.
Maybe they're UFC got rid of them just in time.
It's too bad because against Chris Weidman,
he looked like a bad mother fucker.
That Joe,
I don't think Beltmore gets enough respect.
Their guys are fucking tough at the top level.
Like that's true.
So Maaco hasn't lost the fight and how long yet spend for steroids,
but he's won like six in a row.
He's a motherfucker.
He is a motherfucker.
Do you see when you knocked out Melvin?
Yeah.
Like those,
look at that.
I boom Bella towards going to be a tough going for everybody.
I think that's true.
And that also highlights how fucking good Rory Macdonald actually is.
Look at.
Look at Larkin not doing well.
Yeah,
well Lauren's got owed by Paul Daley is,
you know when you stand in front of Paul Daley,
Paul Daley throws bad.
I talk in bombs.
That left hand is just a ridiculous weapon.
We'll look at Ben Henderson.
He's struggling.
Ben Henderson was on down sod.
He was on the downside when he went there though.
True.
But the struggle city then.
That's just rough.
Dave's trying to go one 70 ah,
that was not a gun.
The guy fought nightmare.
Phil Davis did well,
but you know a Ryan Bader beat him.
You know Ryan Bader who was probably never going to be the champ in the UFC
light heavyweight division.
Now you never know.
You never know.
Jon Jones.
Jon Jones in,
he was really not.
It was everyone though.
They nobody can.
That title John was there.
You know,
you gotta wonder man.
You got to wonder what the fuck.
Actually happened when it came to this steroid stuff.
I was,
I talked to Novitsky like a lot of these,
these,
um,
websites were posting that if John Jones could provide a supplement that had
that stuff in it,
he wouldn't get a suspension.
It is possible that he wouldn't get a suspension.
Novitsky said they just totally took me out of context and that's not what I
said at all.
Yeah.
I listened to what he was actually is it is possible to have tainted supplements
and people have proven in the past.
So there's something in a supplement and if you can prove that you took it
completely accidentally,
which guys have,
you know who did that is um,
uh,
10 means,
yeah,
the dirty bird,
but he got suspended for a few months even even though,
but a few months for John would be a win.
Yeah.
That wouldn't be shit with him.
With his history.
It's tough to believe.
It's just,
I want to believe,
I want to believe too so bad.
I won't back so bad.
And I think the UFC needs them so,
so they need them so bad right now.
What are you excited for these days?
See,
go ahead.
Go ahead Eddie.
I'm finally saw that documentary.
ICARUS.
Oh,
it's fucking him.
Holy Shit.
Fucking amazing.
Right?
That's the Russian doping.
Yes.
Didn't know anything about that movie.
And let's say Alex Jones said the Russians,
they're sneaking into the laboratories there
in the middle of the night and they're switching the urine.
The Asian,
the beach.
I'm telling you,
I know this,
that I have an inside sources.
How could they do that?
It's impossible.
Yes.
I believe that would be the end of Alex Jones right there.
Maybe
that sounds crazy that they were like breaking into the opposite.
Switching the pisses.
Well,
they did it in Russia though.
It was in Sochi.
They won 13 gold medals,
gold medals.
Everyone was dirty to do ted.
Everyone was dirty.
That guy's in serious hiding right now.
Hell yeah,
he is.
He's like fucking Nigga got him tucked away and homeboy who was worried about
them,
right?
Oh yeah,
yeah.
He was saying he has that he's had like depression before and then try to commit
suicide before that scandal first broke out in Russia when he was freaking out.
He was in Russia and he was on the phone going,
they're going to kill it because I need to get,
I need a plane ticket out here.
I was shocked that he was able to leave the country.
Yeah.
What did you think that they were like they would have someone on his ass.
Well,
Bryan Fogel,
who was the director of it,
was on my podcast and he explained to me how they didn't think that he was a
flight risk and they,
cause he was such the mastermind of the program,
they never thought that he was going to take off.
There's a bunch of reasons why he cited on the podcasts that I can't totally
recall why they didn't think that he was going to take off,
but obviously they fucked that one up.
Super fucked up.
He was all see CEO.
Well,
you know what's crazy dude?
How Wada the world antidoping agency and the International Olympic Committee are
all in bed together.
They're not policing each other.
Why does not policing the IOC?
It's bullshit.
That's why they let the Russians in.
Even though they knew the Russians cheated in Sochi,
they had irrefutable proof that they cheated like that.
All the stuff that you've seen,
that Netflix documentary,
ICARUS is 100% true.
They still let him compete in Rio.
All they did is they throw him a bone.
They said,
yeah,
we're going to take out the track and field team.
These.
This track and field team has to go,
so they took the track and field team out.
They left wrestling.
Gymnastics all is a dirty,
dirty,
dirty athletes.
They probably rush,
probably say,
hey listen guys,
if you guys have my back,
we're going to go after you because everybody's doing.
Everybody's doing it.
That's all we'll say else you got sign is 100% doing it.
This degree has been busted a little bit though.
We busted.
Yeah.
American Olympian.
How?
How come on hundred percent a hundred percent all by all the possible like
Russia?
No,
not like Russia because it's not state sponsored.
But if you don't think a lot of them are on it,
the amount of money that you can meet.
He was,
Brian was explaining it.
It's like,
think about someone like Phelps,
right?
Michael Phelps,
because he won because he won the gold medal.
You know how many gold medals you want to shit load.
Right.
Most of us.
That guy is a huge celebrity.
He's wealthy.
Whose phone was that?
That's a us.
The Russian hack on it.
He's fine.
The Russians.
The Russians got Eddie.
Um,
so because of that,
because of that,
that guy makes fucking millions of dollars a year.
But now go to the silver medalist.
Who is that guy?
Who fucks that guy?
Ryan Lochte.
Yeah,
but who,
who is he?
No one knows.
He's a liar.
No one.
The blue here.
That's the guy that got
Rio pretending that they were robbing him.
Yeah,
he was like,
the police had me at gunpoint.
They did.
You broke a bathroom door.
You piece of shit.
Yeah.
He was like,
Dad May,
I can point that told me,
get on the floor.
And I said,
fucking make me
like,
Bro,
you up white jeans on a few.
If you got on the ground,
why don't they dirty at all?
He's like,
I don't know,
clean ground,
you know,
Brazil and
now he's just like fucking laughing stock of all times.
It's just a big old liar when possible to win the hundred meters without being
on juice.
You know that guy a Victor Conte from the ball scandal,
that guy that hooked up Barry bonds and all those people with the in detectable
ultimate snitch of all time.
The ultimate snitch cause he,
he got out of jail and then immediately started stitch to niche away.
Snitch,
snitch darn says the entire track and field sport is a dirty sport.
He said all of them.
He's like,
dude,
he was like,
think about Jamaica.
Jamaica wins all these gold medals.
He's like,
what's going on?
Why?
Why do they,
why are they winning gold medals?
Like what's happening?
He said,
let me tell you what's happening.
They have a very sophisticated drug program.
Jamaica,
like they're not known for being,
they've never been known for being sprinters.
Like,
that's not their thing.
It's kind of knew that that's their thing and that the best ever at it do we
just think it's the fucking plantation?
Like what do you think it is?
Well,
what do you think they're eating?
One of the things that Fogel pointed out,
it's like,
we remember when Ben Johnson got tested positive when he fought,
when he,
uh,
actually raced against Carl Lewis.
Remember that?
He's kind of a big deal.
He was Super Jack Jack Gold chain.
Apparently Carl Lewis tested positive too.
You have,
they're all doing it all over tested positive.
It's just that Ben Johnson's levels were so off the fucking charts.
They were like Jesus.
But that was the first year that they were testing.
It's like pride data before,
it's like pride days.
Yeah,
like pride days.
And that makes you think,
I hate to say this,
but it really makes you think about fate.
Or there's Ben Johnson back in the day sign.
That's a good picture.
But get a picture of him mid sprint.
Jamie,
you can see how fucking Jack,
I'm a fight.
He was,
he was so fucking fast.
Look that
he's so big.
It was so big for a track and field.
Carl Lewis looks he has aids back then.
Look at how jacked Ben John,
he looks like Melvin Manhoef.
That's correct.
Like,
like that kind of build.
Take Adrian Peterson.
So these,
these,
these guys are all,
but they're all freshmen.
They're all on something.
Every one of them's on something.
No white guys got ahold of some good shit.
Go to that one.
The one above that.
Jesus Christ rock.
Yeah.
Love sitting in the fucking sprint.
The 100 meter dash.
It's not hard.
We get juice to the gills.
Not thing.
Where's the white stores?
Yeah,
it's not,
we're not spraying.
Guys aren't willing to go that deep.
We just don't know what we got to go full bane.
I wonder.
I wonder what it is and get his eyes.
First of all,
what the fuck was he taking over his eyes turn yellow.
That's what they had said.
That his liver was struggling to deal with all the steroids in the system and it
was making the whites of his eyes yellow.
Damn.
He still beat the record with that Timex watch on.
That's some powerful shit.
Why is it a Timex slow you down that heavy ass basic.
Watch that though.
But that wouldn't really hold your aerodynamics.
My man's not a bad pen.
The gold chain.
The fucking Rick Ross gold chains.
Gold chains,
a big one.
He went,
I'm going to go to star coaches.
Try to have an intervention.
Say Dude fix bro.
No bitches like gold.
I know bitches.
And I know that arguments.
So powerful.
G Shock Watch and how you shooting it?
Watch that fun.
He does have yellow eyes.
Many looks like a leopard.
Like he's ready to leap on you and no one said anything like Bro,
your eyes and that watcher giveaway going on with your eyes.
Oh,
it's gotta be the first of all time.
And this kind of tracking.
Who's that guy?
Ben Johnson.
That's Ben Johnson for a while.
He was sending both farm maybe?
Yeah.
Is that Ben Johnson there?
Jack Know Hussein ball was another child.
Who were the fees the older guys of all time,
like you said,
false number one.
Carl Lewis over whenever you saying ball has the best time of all time.
Then at the Ben Johnson Bolt Lewis,
how many can you get?
How many sprinters can you name?
Well,
it was seen bullying Jones.
Yeah,
females.
But again,
she came out,
she snitched on herself.
You ever seen a snitch on yourself?
Why?
Why she a snitch on herself?
Because I think there was some rumors and she was like,
I can't handle this anymore.
It was Jews to the gills.
I got a dick,
Joe man,
Hussein bolt.
We'll same bolt.
Tyson gay.
Ooh.
Oh,
Justin Gatlin.
Tyson gay.
I know those.
That's a rough name.
It's a rough name.
Tyson gay.
There ain't a white guy and fucking now Compton
comp.
Wow.
Look how far down you got to go to get to somebody,
you know.
Hussein bolt number 34 like more each green.
Like when do you get down to Ben Johnson?
Did they have them on there or did they take it off?
Yeah,
they took him off yet pushing Coleman.
I bet that they shouldn't take them off.
I mean,
if you want to punish him,
punish him,
but you can't take them off.
It's like what they did with the,
um,
with the Tour de France,
they uh,
they took all the ones that Lance Armstrong one there,
they removed him as a winner.
He won like eight times,
but everybody was dirty.
I had to go down to 15th place to find a guy.
18 was it 18?
Anything was eight.
How about in the Mit guy who didn't test,
but how about a major league baseball?
Like,
no,
barely budge.
Can't be in the hall of fame because you got tested positive,
stupid.
Who the fuck you think was stolen?
The pitches,
their juice to the gills to you fucks.
And what happens with like Sammy Sosa and mark McGwire will have you seen Sammy
Sosa?
That's a
great angle.
Well he had locked it up.
Nice professional triangle right there.
He knew exactly what he was doing.
Yeah,
that's pretty deep.
It took a while to cinch it in,
but
it's a wrap.
Oh No,
shit.
He looked up.
Oh,
the rounds over.
No Way.
Tighten the end of the round.
I think that's why I went for that arm bar.
Wait,
did he tap that on?
But I really wasn't him.
Was it?
I don't know.
No,
the ring.
The ring?
Yeah.
That was a good ending.
Oh,
so it was the end of the round.
Okay,
so we got one more.
But if you want to see what happens when you don't make the hall of fame,
look at,
have you seen Sammy Sosa lately?
Why is the referee checking him his eyes after awhile he got,
he took some punches when he was down.
Uh,
yeah,
I've seen Sammy Sosa lately.
Like if something went crazy,
became a white guy.
Crazy.
Yeah.
He just went from the back to triangle.
Dude,
that's totally pro.
Oh,
this guy's really good.
Oh Dude.
He fucked him up with that.
Right?
This guy's good dude.
Sammy Sosa is a different human being.
I need to acknowledge this.
What did he do?
Look at his skin.
He looks like Michael Jackson.
Yeah.
What happened?
What the fuck?
I'm not sure if he's talking about it.
Has He talked about Jamie?
It looks like you just went,
fuck it.
I want to be white.
Go the one in the pink hat.
Go to pink hat,
sir.
Okay.
That's the greatest baseball player of all time off for a second.
That's what happens.
We don't like isn't the whole thing.
Well,
he might've fucked his body up with all the steroids.
Mcguire's he gay.
Are you saying he's gay?
Is that what you say?
Open.
That's what happened when you don't like gays in the hall of fame that we just
said.
Daphne didn't say that.
I don't think he's gay.
I think Sammy Sosa still lays pipe.
I even though he's weighing both.
Heard gay?
No.
Fuck No.
He just said,
hey,
let's just be real clear.
None of us have a problem with gay people.
I love,
I don't know if gay people
wearing a pink hat because he's gay.
I'm cool with it.
I don't pink shoes.
I don't give a fuck.
Who was you guys talking to Dick?
I'm looking at this though.
Yeah.
What happened?
So what does he say happened to him like,
because it's weird.
He just,
okay,
that's a white guy.
Yeah,
it's crazy.
And he was so dark.
He was dark black.
Yeah.
He was out with a Tan.
Maybe you got it was in the tanning.
Not,
no,
no.
Everything's changed.
You know what?
There is cream.
There's cream that uh,
some women do use to lighten their skin.
Oh,
he had his over.
What happened?
He admits he bleaches the skin.
Oh,
humidity bleaches the skin.
Oh Wow.
That's weird.
I wonder why he wants to do that too.
That's really just the second Michael Jackson.
No,
no,
because Michael Jackson had what I have.
He had to his condition,
but he did bleach your skin though.
He did
it out.
Yeah,
but that's not what Sammy Sosa's doing.
Sammy Sosa just decided to be able to wipes to be white.
People have done that.
Or maybe Michael Jackson's just wanting to be white,
but he used that as an excuse.
No,
he legit and had like a skin thing and it started to spread and he's like,
fuck,
I don't want to look like this.
And just went full spectrum.
Have you seen some models who have it?
They're gorgeous and they're just rocket that.
I think it's sexiest.
Harlow.
I called the zebra models.
They're sexy as fuck.
They got like a cool,
can we see them Jamie?
Well,
it's only one role model is there's any Harlow,
well I call him z.
Here's the triangle.
Right?
But this is not the end of the fight.
Well,
like how did this fight end?
Maybe he gave up at the corner and the car was the last round.
I think that was the third to decision homeboy.
We're doing the worst job of paying attention to this fight.
Dan Hardee with a beautiful green jacket.
Powerful joker colors.
Um,
so Sammy Sosa just decided to be a white.
Just fuck it and say enough is this now I can do a white guy.
Go Black.
No,
I mean you can be a Tanner
tape gets Tate Tate did a movie and Tahiti.
Well you don't get black features.
Well no,
but you don't get black skin.
You get like 10 super dark.
Take got so fucking dark.
No,
Bro.
I'm talking about going straight black,
black,
black fit.
There was a Maurice Povich.
That was Maurice poppage.
What's his name?
Maurice.
Mcgriff morning.
Right?
Black.
You'd be more ready.
Exactly.
Publix.
There was a girl,
some white girl who wants to be black.
Oh,
you seen this?
she said cash me outside,
girl.
No,
no,
no.
She's like,
really wants to be black.
It's a white woman who,
who uh,
and the audience is all black and they fucking can't stand there.
And they're just baring.
Or is that the home girl who got fired from her job?
Look at this.
What Sammy Sosa says.
What happened was that I had been using the cream for a long time and that
combined with the bright TV lights made my face look wider than it really is.
I don't think I look like Michael Jackson.
He added,
apparently Sosa has kept up,
has used cream over the years,
which has led him to appear even wider than he did in 2009 so he's been just
getting wider and wider and wider.
Okay.
Go higher there.
It's a bleaching cream that I applied before going to bed and widens my skin
tone.
Social said during the appearance of Univision's,
blah,
blah.
It's a cream that I have that it used to soften my skin,
but it has bleached me some.
I'm not a racist.
I live my life happily.
What bleached me some sir,
you were completely a light man.
Racist.
I'm not a racist.
Maybe like there was like a super racist white check that he was trying to fuck
and he's like,
there's only one way and say,
hey guys,
I got to be,
you never know you never go full white unless she was just bad.
She just was like,
like Taj Tennessee racist but with big old titties,
big plump pink titties and now he's just flocked to take any little waist.
But I just put on a bleaching cream.
I don't know that Michael Jackson cream.
It's no big deal.
I put a little bit on before I go to sleep at night.
It's a little bleaching cream.
What's the ideal kind of see what the problem.
Meanwhile he said he's even lighter than he was in 2009 I mean he's talking
about something that happened eight years ago.
He's lied to than that now.
He's also a little mentally unstable cause he also has white man here now he's
like the straight white like fuck God damn dark Tate.
God.
Jesus Christ takes a savage.
Yeah.
I mean he's Tan,
but you wouldn't confuse him for being black.
Well you would if he had black features and black hair.
No,
for sure.
If he had an Afro,
you would say that's a light skinned black guy.
You think,
fuck yeah,
100%.
Like a dark.
Come back to that picture again.
Look at that.
Got My IA as dark as fuck.
And we get Photoshop Steve to put,
uh,
um,
I mean if you change is Eric Curl on?
It's probably already on it.
Yeah,
he's probably right.
Probably all be blank.
Better than others.
My favorite meme a online is that one black dude is going like this.
Oh yeah.
Yeah.
You never get in the eye.
It looks like the Reading Rainbow Guy.
I don't know who that guy is.
Derek Brunson.
Machida back.
Yeah.
Against Derek Brunson can help for a minute.
The,
you can't get if you don't get into a relationship.
He looks like Ben Johnson a little bit.
There's an animated Gif of him.
Do it at two.
It's even better.
And animated one.
I haven't seen that one.
Yeah,
the,
that,
that's a part of them under the,
there he is.
That's the animated one.
Who is this?
Just some dude.
Oh,
it's amazing.
He's a rapper.
Do you know our problem?
He's a Jamaican rapper.
Did you know that?
They have me cards now and people like they have like games.
They play with meme cards and he's one of the meme cards and there's always the
one,
there's
the one where I forget who it is,
some another rapper while he's standing like this.
Like what?
Like that picture.
Awesome.
And then there was the,
you know,
the,
the black lady with the Hump for neck and two or what
have you seen?
The one of the kitties like in school and he's like this and there's other,
and it's like vegans when they haven't talked about being a Vegan for a minute.
That's hilarious.
Yeah.
See The meme,
the Games,
see,
look at this.
It's a fucking game.
You played this game like in the,
I don't know how it works,
but you deal these things out like these popular memes.
It's hilarious.
Guy gets laid for that,
ma'am.
Probably Damien Maia versus Colby Covington.
Ooh,
that's an interesting,
that's an interesting fight.
You know what,
man?
I just switched Damien.
Why Maya was younger because without this sauce,
without the special sauce,
you know he's like 40 years old now.
Yeah,
but I mean he said even when he was young,
he was a beast.
He's a beast,
like to remember he went on the whole kind of tear and then fly to Anderson.
Terrible fight back down,
cut to 79 he's a beast again.
He's still a beat.
He's still,
he's 100% of beach when she was young.
Why?
Because I love the idea of a specialist.
I'm always fascinated by a specialist,
by a guy who just does one thing better than everybody else.
Can he do it to somebody that's been Estrin the fight I would do.
It's been asking Damien Maia,
I wish Ben didn't retire because I want that fight.
Ben's never going to get in the UFC.
He talked way too much shit about,
about Dana white like that.
Those are those days still there.
I feel like Dana White didn't give a fuck anymore that much money.
Like what Ben asking me,
I let them know don't give a fuck.
I don't know man.
Why have a men then what if he talks more shit about you?
You,
we need ratings.
Ben Asked her and doesn't give a f uh,
he's,
he's retiring,
right?
Yeah.
It's a bummer.
Undefeated,
retiring,
undefeated.
But it's interesting because the only one who gave them any problems really was
a j here on j Iran got him to a split decision a long time ago though.
Yeah.
But it doesn't matter.
It was like a wrestler who could strike a guy who was good enough to keep you
away,
you know,
good enough wrestling to keep it from being a wrestling match and he could
strike.
But Ben evolved from there cause Ben with,
with Woodley,
with all these old guys,
like he evolved his game.
So he talked to people and they're like,
dude,
he's dead.
We can handle the stress.
One guy that gave us some trouble,
some Russian Daggett Stan type of wrestler guy who claimed it was on one FC,
he was calling Ben outside.
I could out Russell,
you,
I'm gonna take you down real.
And he did and he was on them for awhile,
but Ben still beat him.
He got him an arm.
Such a shame.
He never gotten the UFC man fucking judge track except for that guy.
Everybody that he gets his mitts on as soon as Ben like holds you or grabs you,
his clinch is so high level that you just can't break free of his,
his clan,
you know,
it's a bummer is one of the reasons,
obviously you talk shit to Dana,
but that style for a lot of people isn't going to sell paper views or get
ratings because of that on wrestling,
holding,
holding people down.
He hears he's getting good at summit.
So many guys now too.
She doesn't care,
but they're not going to.
Here's the problem with that logic.
Floyd Mayweather style of boxing is not fan friendly either,
but Floyd,
major superstar before that he did knock people out,
became the guy you'd either pay to watch him lose or win.
Huge draw [inaudible] not a big draw.
Introduce him wasn't,
he was not a huge drop before he started talking shit to people.
It wasn't a huge draw until he became money Mayweather.
I became the bad guy.
That's when he became a huge drum.
A bad guy,
but also fought Oscar,
Dela Hoya,
all the,
all the superstars spend Africans that come in the UFC and then go night.
Here's,
here's Connor Mcgregor,
some superstar there.
The UFC is not going to do that.
He doesn't have the style either,
but if he did that would be very,
very interesting.
Yeah,
but but what I'm saying is that's the only way that this guy could become famous
is by shit talking.
The shit talking is what's going to make them famous.
Like people wanting to see him lose.
That's what makes a guy like that famous because his style is very appealing to
guys like us that are like,
I want to see if he can do is,
you know what?
It takes a while to evolve and and be a good finisher.
And at first for awhile they were just taking people down and just owning them
and controlling of John.
But he's good at submitting people now he gets,
he gets a great grappler overall.
It's great.
So now,
so now the w the Ben asks,
can we have now you can't compare them to the Ben.
Ask him from five years ago.
That's gone.
There's a Ben ass grin that's going to take you down and choke you out.
Now Eddie,
that whole different,
that's gone.
He's retired and money will be,
there's also the other,
nobody's really return fc allowing him to use knees to the head on the ground.
What'd you say?
One FC allowed him to use knees to the head on the ground.
Right.
It's a good point.
Yeah.
That's a big weapon and didn't kicks.
You see Brett,
what Brandon and bear did over there?
Kicking dudes in the face,
kick him in the back of the head and they're down.
It's like a champion.
Yeah.
You think he's on the Jews?
They took off.
They took out the soccer kicks.
Now you have seen,
well the,
did you see,
um,
a homeboy Roger Huerto get SAS that was raw.
That's why you can't have soccer kicks.
He was fighting a Brazilian who was a big fella who was cutting to make one 70
and Roger's not really a one seven.
He was one 55 in the UFC decided to fight one 70 and he was getting beat up and
then you went down and this dude's soccer kicked him into the next fucking can't
have that and be a professional sport.
It's just too,
it's too brutal.
I don't know,
man.
I mean,
he hasn't really,
he didn't go back on the trial.
Yeah.
I mean it was a brutal,
brutal knockout.
They're tough to watch.
That one was particularly that you see when cro,
cop kicked run waterman.
I mean,
it's fucking hard.
It's hard to watch.
But why is it harder to watch than a regular head kick?
That's my question.
Is it because there's a lot of head kick,
you kind of move more with it and the soccer kick you lying down already Carter
to defend when you're lower.
I think it can generate power,
right?
Yeah,
for sure.
Like Charlie Brown kick someone in
the face.
I think I could kick someone just as hard to the body.
I don't know.
I think you'd be surprised.
You mean Dan kick harder on the ground?
Fuck yes.
Like think about an NFL kicker.
Yeah,
I like kicking like straight like that.
No,
I don't think so dude.
I'm pretty sure that I could kick just as hard to the body as I could to the,
to the ground.
I don't think so.
Joe.
I think just kept question is up high.
I don't,
I think up high would lose something.
I lose a little bit up high just from like the leverage,
but I think I did because I think your leg going straight like this and low.
I think that's where the most of the power is going to be.
Right.
And guaranteed all shit and guaranteed all shit.
Depends on what kind of kick,
cause here's the thing you could spinning back,
kick someone in the face when they're down too.
That's another thing to think about.
Think about
God attorney sign yours.
Not all of them,
but think about that like a dude gets hit.
He goes down on one knee and you flogging Jj.
Gay People are gonna die.
We're gonna die.
Yeah,
I mean if your face is right there and you took a full power turning side kick
to the face,
he'll get Brandon.
He's so jack now.
He's so thick.
This is a,
this is the one when he came the dude and kicked him to the head when he was on
the ground,
remember when he beat frank man,
it was like,
I'm taking light heavyweight and heavyweight over.
Well you know what happened with him?
Oh beautiful.
Straight left.
He's looking at this soccer kicks to the back of the head.
That's shit's rough.
Those kind of kicks to the back of the header.
Forget that noise.
Brandon Pharaoh,
he's a good guy,
man.
Oh,
he's a good guy.
Great Guy.
Good guy.
I was always a fan of his,
but you know,
he started out as a heavyweight and then dropped down the light heavyweight with
the big thing that happened to him in the UFC was he went to this big prolonged
contract negotiation wanting to get paid.
He wants to get paid and when he came back to tremendous amount of pressure on
him,
he just didn't perform the same as he did before.
Then he fought Fabricio for breeze over doom,
got on top of him and put the squished down on him and beat the shit out of him.
Fabrizio was Mount,
oh,
this should be interesting.
Like yawn,
Blah.
[inaudible] Mark Goddard again in the motherfucking house.
Who is the gentleman that,
uh,
the whole,
which is fighting
Devon Clark and Clark do not know Mr Clock.
There's the golden snitch right to the left.
Oh,
I didn't see him.
He ran a parents checking piss right things.
He's got a little magnifying glass.
Right?
He doesn't have a hit out on you.
Vials,
shaking the files.
Anybody should have a hit on him.
It should be IMG or WME rather.
Right people that bought an EOC,
EOC.
Dude,
you're fucking up our business.
They should find that Russian dude that they got in hiding.
Bring him,
bring him in June promotion.
Give no Wicki Sona position and say,
Look Jeff,
you did a great job,
but we're going a different direction.
They're going to give to,
right.
We've got a different job for you.
Kick rocks and you're
no,
keep them on.
You don't want to fire him because then they'll talk some shit.
Oh Jeff,
we uh,
you got a new,
you actually in marketing.
Yeah.
You make amazing marketer.
We need you to run the social media and shut the fuck up.
Dump his.
Does he have them run the UFC performance institute?
Hey piss boy.
You're just stating,
hey piss boy,
you stay at the UFC institute now and just keep your mouth shut.
You know what?
You're going to make your make shakes now you're making shakes for the UFC.
No,
no,
no.
You got to give him a prestigious position.
No,
we call,
we say it's prestigious,
but you just do that and we pay you out the ass to shut the fuck up.
How would you make some hemp protein shakes and shut the fuck up.
Yeah.
Just have a monitor.
The dudes that are on the treadmill job guys.
There you go guys.
That hose in your mouth when they run with the hose,
you know like what are you fucking rocky cold towel.
You guys need [inaudible] that should be as Gig.
Ultimate piss boy.
Oh,
that's hilarious.
That UFC performance institute is fucking amazing.
I'm seeing it come alive.
You know,
I'm the next UFC in Vegas.
You should come with me and we'll,
we'll take a trip.
I went cold.
I went there.
Did you?
A couple of weeks ago you had a meeting there about fight pass,
right about a ebi and combat Jujitsu.
How'd that go?
Good,
good,
good.
You know,
uh,
did it or
we're still in the code for negotiations about
Combat Jujitsu,
which is in three in three weeks.
But um,
uh,
it's looking good.
And so then it's like they've been doing a lot of promotion.
I know of Ebi on fight pass,
like during the fights total,
we've had some tough times promotion.
They sat us down,
they sat us down and said,
listen,
look,
well look what we do for you.
They put all the presentation goes every time we mentioned you guys on this show
or that show up when you know how much that's worth,
they broke it down for us.
And we're like,
fuck,
that's pretty bad ass
contract negotiations with them.
That's what's going on.
Could Combat Jiu Jitsu is a new,
it's a,
it's an offshoot.
It's a spin off from Ebi.
It's a hundred percent combat.
You get to two strikes and you're trying to sell that to we're,
we're putting on the show and the UFC wants to be part of it.
And I just really can't explain exactly how,
but we're,
we're gonna figure it out within the next week.
Gotcha.
And um,
but
uh,
if you don't know what combat get is,
it's basically in between sub only Jujitsu and MMA.
It's not,
I'm in May,
but it's not sub only.
It's right there.
It's,
it's for Jujitsu fanatics who are just interested in seeing,
you know,
there's,
there's like guys that are really into kickboxing and they know everything about
kickboxing,
but they'll watch MMA a little bit,
you know what I mean?
But they're there.
They're in the kickboxing there in the business.
And then there's guys like that unboxing.
Sure.
We'll watch a little lemon mag.
Well there's guys like that and Jujitsu to a lot of guys in Jujitsu.
Do not watch the UFC.
You know why?
Because they're showing,
did you do,
did they want to see Jujitsu?
The watch did Jujitsu again,
but they're not interested in kickboxing.
Just like a kickboxing guy's not interested in watching digital matches.
So there's a lot of different genres and um,
combat.
You'd get this for the,
the Jujitsu freak that wants to watch Jujitsu.
Competition with a little more realism,
a little bit closer to MMA.
When you add palm strikes,
the importance of each position changes tremendously.
Like in the suburban gangs in this way.
Well,
well,
in the sub only game,
that's one aspect.
And the sub only game.
Uh,
the full guard is not important at all.
If you never want to play full guard,
that's on you.
You don't have to,
you could win Abu Dhabi in the point system without ever playing full guard.
You could win.
Full guard is so not important in some the only,
and in point grappling,
he supplied what you're allowed to do when you allowed to do and come back.
He tries,
he punched it all.
No,
yet it's palm strikes.
It's aunt when standing,
it's just wrestling.
It's not MMA.
It's not a mimic.
It's extreme Jujitsu.
You got to look at it.
So wrestling is just standing.
It's just wrestling.
But as soon as someone hits the ground,
you can start throwing palm strikes.
Right.
You know,
but no elbows to the body,
no elbows,
no punches.
Just pause.
Helps rights to the body's,
nothing.
Just palm strikes.
And so it's like,
remember the old Gracie in action videos?
All those challenge matches in Brazil.
They had rules.
They're like,
they were just palm strikes in Jujitsu.
Those were rules.
So after we did the first combat Jujitsu tournament at Ebi 11 that's when I
first introduced it.
Horian Gracie calls me,
I never talked to Horian Gracie,
however,
he called Rhodes Gracie to get my number.
He wanted to call me and Pam on the phone with Horian Gracie and he's thanking
me for putting together combat.
Jujitsu is Eddie.
This is how we used to do it in Brazil.
I wanted had it to do this,
but hell,
he could not do this.
This is what we want to thank you.
This is the real Jujitsu,
you know?
And I'm like,
Holy Shit.
The guy who invented the UFC correct.
Calls me up.
And what happens is when God consequently makes a fifth,
it's a foul.
It's like a foul and get taken away.
Like,
like how many can fulfill?
It's still,
it's still no points.
We call this finish only because in the first 10 minutes,
if there's not a submission or a Tko,
I mean,
or the,
that's the only way he could finish.
Then we go into overtime,
like Ebi overtime,
but there has to be a finish.
So we call it finished.
I wouldn't get knocked out.
People can not done yet.
We did two,
we did two four man tournament.
We did a girl won the last show and we did a at Ebi 11 like six months ago.
We did the first one.
Now we're doing a whole show combat.
You did two worlds.
One a whole show.
Jay and Gary.
Tony is going to be in it.
Vagner Rocha is going to be in it.
So tomorrow you're going to see Gary Tone and in Vagner Rocha going at at Ebi
Style and then three weeks later you're going to see them going at it with palm
strikes.
Wow.
How cool is that?
Palm strikes is interesting because you remember when boss Rutan burst onto the
scene and in pancreas was lightened motherfuckers on firewood.
Palm strikes.
Yes.
Instead of swinging like a bitch,
when he figured out it's you pull the palm strikes and throw punches,
just you throwing punches,
all that hand.
A lot of it.
So no,
no.
That was the rules.
Yeah,
I know.
But he was saying,
but even when he went to MMA,
he said he would keep the same thing even if it was a rule or not.
Consider you wouldn't break his hand.
Well you definitely can keep through a lot of punches for sure.
But he would still throw hooks and stuff with open hand.
It's not,
look,
it's,
it's the thing about the palm is it's not much softer and punching somebody.
But you don't hurt your hand at all.
Like if you got a guy like Bas Rutten who really knows how to do it well,
like boss has weird wrists.
He could pull his hand way further than I can.
Like he pulls his hand way back,
like he gets his hand like back there.
So he's basically just fucking palm some words on it.
I bet he does.
That's embarrassing.
Yes.
So what happens with college Jujitsu is the importance of the positions change.
Like all of a sudden when there's palm strikes,
full guard is garde.
Yeah.
Garde would be trouble.
You can't be half card like necessary.
And all of Jiu Jitsu.
There's guys that when Abu Dhabi multiple times never put anybody in there full
guard.
It's so unnecessary.
But when there's palm strikes,
it's the most important.
So it's better to prepare for MMA with that.
That's what's,
that's another reason.
So aspiring grapplers that want to start working on like MMA type Jujitsu and
Jujitsu positions and focus on the positions that are going to translate to MMA.
Better Combat Jujitsu.
We'll get their fee sites,
they'll get to practice,
you'll get to practice and then made Jujitsu without worrying about getting head
kicked or something.
You know what I mean?
That's what it's for.
It's for the,
the Jujitsu fanatics.
Did they,
they like to see MMA when there's Jujitsu.
Well with combat you did,
it's going to be mostly Jujitsu.
Well you know when,
whenever they like move rules around and combat sports,
it makes it interesting.
Like that's what they did with k one they took Moyie Thai and I said,
you know what,
there's clinch you guys clinched two months.
The elbows cut people up,
you know,
needs to the fee.
Let's cut all the fucking clench with the needs to the face.
Like holding in knee and let's just have it turn into kickbox.
Yeah,
try to make it better.
they just tried to make it more exciting.
Yeah.
There's going to be for guys that like MMA when there's the Jujitsu in it.
Now we're going to get pure or animate style Jujitsu and we don't have to worry
about the striking.
We love [inaudible].
We love all that,
but this is just for the hardcore Jujitsu guys.
We're going to get some,
a lot of data on what leg lock positions are going to go out the door.
It's in the sub only game.
Shit.
You can go for any goddamn light leg lock you won,
but when they're striking,
we're gonna now at that one and that one's too risky.
Let's just stick with these right here and that's what we're going to find that
guys working their ground and pound like are guys like getting a bag and just
fucking Bam cheese tomorrow.
Fuck,
can I,
can I like,
you know,
if I'm in guard and I'm on top,
can I posture up?
Yes.
If as long as the guys on the ground you could stand up,
you can be in a horse stance and throw pumps.
Just tomorrow it tomorrow at Ebi 13 it's a regular sub only 16 man tournament,
but we're also having a
four.
We're having a Forman combat Jujitsu tournament would Richie Martinez.
We just missed the knockout blow,
but it's just knock somebody out and showing what's Bobby's up too.
He's a real vet with a body of he's jacked.
He's a very wide,
yeah,
he is.
It's a little cold.
Was watched what happened in the replay.
Might've missed a couple of leg days,
whatever.
It just stopped to fight for some reason and then it came back like right away.
Knocked him out or something.
They stopped it.
Then we're like go and he knocked him out.
I missed why you stopped it.
I was trying to reset the clock and I look back up.
It's over.
Well,
we'll get a look at the replay here.
Um,
here we go.
Oh,
left hook counter that wobbled on.
oh.
Oh you got,
I'm going to standing chuck.
Wow,
that's pretty dope.
It's better than a knockout right there I come.
Sweet.
He's all messed up and the chokes and I'm way more dramatic than a knockout
right there.
He got sent to rear naked,
choke against the fence.
No hooks.
Somebody had some ridiculous elbow knockout yesterday.
I don't know.
How about Heather Hardy?
Oh,
have you seen this Eddie?
So she was ridiculous box.
I mean one of the best female box of all time.
He's like,
Hey,
I want to try MMA.
She had a good first fight.
Matt Square Garden.
She fought last night.
This girl had three fights,
but you know,
I know the girl had zero MMA,
MMA fight,
three amateur amateur mn pro debut in in Bella Toby.
But she was a kickboxer and she kicked this girl's fucking Faisal.
Heather rolled like Heather rolled like to do inbox and that girl went,
Hey Kim.
Oh well the girl was beating her ass before that.
Did you see her elbows?
Yeah.
Like Heather was like,
yeah,
she didn't know what to do.
She thought she was in a safe position and also the girl was lighting her up
from the outside with kicks.
She was a kickboxing champion,
undefeated and kickboxing,
undefeated in taekwondo,
I think undefeated in boxing.
So the girl like knew how to strike.
I root for Heather.
Man,
you hear a story,
it's fucking fascinating story.
Well she was living with her,
I think her mom,
her grandma and she had a daughter and they're all living like a one bedroom
place in New York and she was like,
I'm going fucking crazy.
Be in the house with the baby.
All the,
I just need an hour to go work out.
So it was like,
oh there's a boxing gym down the street.
She goes,
walks in the boxing gym,
starts to work out and they're like,
damn,
you're not bad at this.
Boom.
Next thing you know,
you know monster,
cause she didn't run into that chick monster.
We'll box and I think Heather would that fucking fight man and be a different
story.
Yeah.
I don't know about all that super high level box.
She is.
That girl can box too.
She's an undefeated kickboxing record as well.
No,
Jay here you,
Heather's a monster.
But her control of distance was what's important.
And when she was standing in front of her,
she would kick and then she'd move to another angle and mix it up.
John Stop.
And Heather's wanted to kind of getting close and play that dirty boxing game.
Well,
big thing was the distance.
You know,
Christina Williams was fighting completely outside.
I mean if you've got to close the distance and you can't throw kicks,
like if you're a boxer and you can't throw kicks and the other person can box a
little and they can kick good like his girl,
Ken,
you're fucked man.
Those kicks hit you a couple of times and the arms and all of sudden those arms
don't work so good anymore.
You know,
and then you're,
you're Super Turkey.
No rhythm.
Then you see Heather,
then she tried rolling like you do from a left hook or something like that and
that fucking kick hit her so hard man Shin right to the face.
And your nose is just destroyed.
Like she's never going to look the same again.
It was pretty girl to,
yeah,
they're going to have to redo her.
It's a bummer cause you know the or belters bank on her to kind of be the next
big thing to care that women's division kills her.
But that kind of loss is a tough one because you get your face caved in again.
Your face cave did is not just loose on about cyborg style.
Michael Bennett page.
It's just,
yeah,
the face is so fucked up like that.
Like you,
you just got to wonder like how long would it take before that girl could even
fight again?
Did you see Michael Venom page professional boxing debut?
Granted the fuck he fought was foreign 70 whatever.
He murked that dude and he did it in a weird way.
Hands Down,
leaped for the straight right,
blasted him and then just stepped on the ropes and looked away.
How exciting is that?
He's fun,
man.
He would be a big star in the UFC and Bella Bella tour.
They just,
they just do not get the credit that they deserve.
I mean,
I agree.
No one gets the credit they deserve,
but you know he's a big star,
but they're like in London,
he's a big Kim and Paul Daley is going to happen.
Oh yeah.
Well I hope it happens.
It's going to happen.
It is a video.
Jamie,
you find a video of the pumps.
It is.
It's kind of crazy.
Watch how he does this,
his style,
so,
oh
yeah.
He's kind of comical that.
That's a serious right hand holds so much stepping into it.
So much momentum behind that.
Rory Macdonald's on my showtime at how you'd like to fight him eventually.
Yeah.
It'd be a fun fight.
Although if we're just taking the mantle him wrestling shoes with,
just pick them apart.
He would dismantle them.
The problem is Roy is not easy to hit.
He's,
he's,
he's very good on his feet.
Stay behind the jab if he wants it.
He got ahold of Michael and Michael's fucked,
which used to do.
Yeah,
he's just too high level.
Rory has just one of the most comprehensive games,
the hundred 70 pound division in the world.
He's the best welterweight in the world.
He very well could be jail.
He beat Woodley.
Yeah,
but then last,
you know,
I think you know what man?
Hofeld dose on Joe's fighting Robbie Lawler.
God Damn,
that's a good fight.
The good fight.
They were going to learn a lot about dose on.
Joe said one 70 Dosantos at one 70 it looks like a fucking murderer.
It looks like the same guy at one 55 I think when when he was making that mad
Ron at one 55 you know when he got to the end and he lost the Alvarez,
he was just cutting too much way.
He couldn't do it anymore.
Too much weight and now you see him at one 75 it looks more comfortable.
It's got more power and he's beating the fuck out of people.
And then she ate Neil magni though.
Fuck ate a mom.
I'm a grand through him.
Like it was like a world champion fighting a journeyman.
That's what it was like.
I wouldn't have been a journeyman.
I was like,
listen,
I love you Neil.
But it looked like fucking amateur hour.
He smashed him.
Well,
Neil's always going to have problems with the real elite guys on the ground.
Grapplers is just,
that's his downfall.
That's an Achilles heel.
Everyone else he influx with tell them gas slim.
He's beat top level guys,
but if they're really,
really good on the ground,
but let's be honest about why beat Calvin.
Calvin was overweight and he came in and he tried to cut too much weight and he
was just diminished.
I think Calvin in shape is just way too much for him.
That's my opinion.
I just think Calvin's one of the best in the world.
I'm not saying he's not,
I'm saying but matchup lies that Stephanie's can be a tough fight for Calvin.
Calvin can do things to him that he can't do to Calvin.
Calvin knocks people dead and he doesn't.
Neil is like got incredible cardio Longreach but he just kind of picks guys upon
range.
Deep arounds.
Most impressed with him was when he fought a tester.
Hector Lombard Lombard had him dead.
He had in my queer streaming pizza.
What you want about Neil,
but he'd be Tiger Lombard,
Johnny Hendricks and Kelvin Gas.
Yup.
We're up class and he's definitely a world class fighter,
but that's how good dose Angelo says.
Dos Anjos kicked him one time to Alexis his legs when he took him for him to
these fucking took them down with a leg,
kick his ass up.
Hey leg kicked him to the ground.
Have you seen a size of dulse?
San Angelo says legs at one 72 she shows so much bigger.
It's just so much healthier for him to all these.
I just,
Dina said something recently that he doesn't think that a more weight classes
are the solution to weight cutting.
I disagree.
The solution wherever we're doing is not working because there's no one misses
more weight than that.
55 and 70 well how about Kevin Lee?
I mean,
Kevin,
if,
if they're,
if they've got everything locked down,
how does Kevin Lee barely make it to one 55 it looks like he's on death's door
and he's 19 pounds over two days.
Who has it locked down?
You're saying?
I'm saying they don't have it locked fuck sets.
It's the biggest issue.
Well besides some other things,
but it's one of the biggest issues in our sport and now Kevin has said,
Kevin has said he can't do it anymore.
He's gonna,
he's gonna move up.
He said this weight cut.
Damn.
Yeah,
he's got to move up.
That's staffing helping.
Yeah,
it's going to one seven.
Yeah.
You just got to do same day when yeah,
he,
nobody will take a chance.
No one would kill themselves if it's same day when they wouldn't take a chance.
That's why like Ibj Jab does that.
Ebi does that same day.
You're going to take a chance.
You can't take a chance.
You just got to compete at what you're really at all understanding covered.
They go,
damn,
I got a date.
We can cut all this and kill myself.
I'll have 24 hours to recover.
And you don't have like I'd be dead jam.
They make you weigh in and then you fight.
Right.
Looking at him there,
but you know,
I love Kevin.
He knows,
but you know Tony cut a bunch of weight.
He figured it out.
Yeah.
But Tony was like three pounds over like a couple days out.
But like two weeks before Tony and Tony goes down,
he has it down to us.
He's a soldier dude.
I mean,
but they don't fucking know.
But it also,
if you're Dana,
you,
you need more weight classes cause it's fucking your,
your,
your business up because it could be,
I mean,
we can't put any money on them.
You can congress never going fight him.
He's not fighting Tony next.
Tony don't want to fight him.
Like,
dude,
you can't even make it.
Wait.
Barboza maybe who's going to type our buzzer?
Beep is,
it can be
a Bentley.
He's got according to Cormier and he's got a new nutritionist and the
nutritionist has got him on point.
Look,
it's a discipline issue.
It's got to keep the Tiramisu.
Tiramisu.
I don't give a fuck if,
you know,
it's definitely a discipline issue,
but it's also a psychological issue.
You think Tony is going to fight.
Conor,
you think that's going down?
I asked to make us host.
Conor made that post to Tony Today.
He made an instrument.
The GTA post.
Yeah.
Grand theft auto with him holding a gun or driving a boat.
Cause Tony did it.
Cause Tony had at first,
right?
Well Tony was talking shit about him.
He called the mcnugget and all this stuff.
Tony Post,
he's a shit,
but didn't Tony originally posted the GTA meme and then Connor responded with
his or vice versa.
I think it's vice versa.
I think Connor went out.
Tony,
look,
Connor Smart,
he realizes that Tony's a unusual eccentric character.
Yeah,
he wrote Tony.
Conor is an unusual [inaudible] has got a bag of cash in the back.
Connors and unusual Accenture care.
Tony's and unusual Accenture character too.
And Tony,
look,
Tony has the longest winning streak in the UFC,
has 155 pound division.
He is the interim champion and he's the logical one.
10 in a row for God's sakes.
And the toughest division in the world.
He's a bad motherfucker.
No doubt.
Here's the problem at champion.
Here's the problem with that,
and I,
I 100% think Connor has to fight Tony next.
If you want to be taken serious and your legacy,
you have to fight Tony.
But if you're tall,
if you're Connor's business decision makers,
you're going look at Tony's draw for paper view though.
This can be tough for us to sell this thing.
Well,
yes,
but not with Connor.
Like Connor cells,
like fucking crazy and controversies Tony cells because Tony's a legit threat.
Connor versus my mom sells.
Right?
But Connor verses a legit threat.
Cells like Connor fighting,
someone sells.
But Connor verses a legit threat is where it gets interesting is the big fight.
That's the big fire.
All.
I agree.
It's only Julio.
You kidding?
He's arrived everybody.
He's a character.
Yeah,
but Eddie,
that's right.
But the paper view numbers were fucking terrible.
Awful.
They're terrible.
Well,
well,
but don't get me wrong.
It takes two to tango.
It does Connor.
But you're Kevin within reason,
the biggest name on the planet.
He said,
everybody respects him in the game because they know he's a beast.
He's coming up fucking people up,
choking people out left and right.
They know he's a beast,
but the world really didn't know him yet.
Correct.
You know what I mean?
The world doesn't know either of them.
And there was a lot of concerning.
Now the world knows Tony.
There was a lot of customers,
a lot of controversy.
Penn,
Kevin's,
Tony for sure.
The whole world doesn't know Tony,
but the MMA world knows Tony for sure.
But the regular people,
the people that you need to get ahold of,
nor to really buy paper views because the world knows nay.
And that's where,
that's a businessman,
Doug WMS go,
well,
let's do Nate,
which if you look at any poll,
I did a poll or Hawaii to pull him away,
junkie.
Everyone goes,
no,
Tony First,
since the fucking fight,
you're talking hundreds of thousands of votes.
People go,
Tony Ferguson,
the next fight.
But WME is going,
yeah,
put the money's over here.
But the nae fights not going anywhere.
And how long are you gonna let Connor play this kind of weird makeup,
a fight game thing with Nate.
Nate made 4 million bucks over two fights and he don't give a fuck.
He's like,
pay me.
You gotta pay me.
But he's gone pay for what you're,
you've lost four the last seven.
You know what I'm saying?
Yeah.
But he beat Conner and then the second fight,
he arguably how to draw with Connor,
but he lost.
He lost a decision based on a couple of people's opinion,
but I think if you went and saw the attars Joe,
but it doesn't matter.
It doesn't.
Public opinion means a lot.
If you went online and you ask people who you think won that fight,
I bet you would get very close to 50 58 versus Connor.
Doesn't matter.
But then when Lassi does matter in terms of how you sell the fight,
it doesn't because to sell the fight,
if,
if Nate would have won,
if those three people and have a winning,
you don't have a third fight
fight after he beats twice in a row after you beat Eddie Alvarez,
you absolutely could have a third fight.
He absolutely,
especially not if they beat them twice.
That's not true.
Not True.
Especially if he beat him by the same decision.
If the had the exact same fight and Nate one that decision,
which was entirely feasible,
right?
The second fight was so close that you could easily have given it to Nate.
If Nate winds that second fight,
she's beaten them twice in a row,
you know,
think to after condor knocks out Eddie Alvarez the way he did.
If Connor fought Alvarez,
knocked him out.
You don't think you could sell a third fight because it was so god damn razor
close.
God.
Oh,
and to,
I guess here you're looking at the numbers.
You see the problem with decisions is these decisions are solidified by three
people that oftentimes don't even have a fucking background in MMA.
Correct decisions off all the time.
That doesn't mean a lot to me.
What it means a lot to me is how close to fight was.
That's what means a lot to me.
If a guy goes over to see me,
touch somebody on the trilogy,
what do we get more cards from that fight?
Yeah,
474748474847 that's his fucking close as it gets.
It's a majority decision.
One guy scored it a draw.
Glenn Trowbridge.
I do not remember what I thought,
whether I thought it was uh,
uh,
went to Connor or went to,
you know what?
I don't think I've watched it again.
I'm pretty sure I only watched that fight.
It was a close fucking fight.
Very super razor close.
We've seen decisions like in fights that weren't as close go to the other,
but no one got robbed in that fight.
I wouldn't say Nate got robbed.
I would say that it's a controversial decision because anytime you have a
majority decision,
there's some controversy to it.
But my point is you could easily sell that fight,
even if Connor,
even if needed one.
I think there's other sites,
bigger fights,
if you know what is,
what does a bigger fight if Nate fought Conor,
you don't.
You think there's a bigger fight than that.
If you're saying,
hold on,
Joe,
what do you say?
Trying to fight you.
So you're saying if Nate beat them twice,
the third fights can be the big fight.
Right now you see this beat?
I'm stuff.
It's the same exact fight.
Okay.
The same exact fight takes place.
God Damn Man.
When they lose the same exact fight,
the same exact fight,
those three random fucking people,
they decide,
you know what,
this 47 47 I'm going to go 48 47 Diaz and then the 48 47 goes,
you know what?
I think it's the opposite.
I think it's 48 it's not a make believe world cause it's entirely feasible that
that could have done that ever happen.
And Tony,
Jesus Christ and you listening to me,
it's entirely possible that that could have happened in the exact same fight.
It's still the same fight.
The see the fight was very close.
Those guys were rivals,
man in Nate choked him the fuck out and the correct,
right.
That's always going to be there.
So even if Connor like got real close Connor,
such a superstar that if he lost a close decision,
the second fight,
you get absolutely make an argument for a third fight,
especially with one or two spectacular performances like the Eddie Alvarez.
So if we're going off that we can do any fight.
Let's,
let's do Joseph Aldo.
He could say,
Oh that was a freak accident.
13 seconds.
Let's run that back.
That's a huge aspect for sure.
And then that's when Eddie Alvarez back,
if you'd be stressing the thing about a yard and he stops,
he beat the shit out of Eddie Alvarez and then knocked him out.
Eddie was never in that fight.
All the spring Chatman is back cause he did it.
He took it on a six week,
six day notice on a bad idea.
But Chad [inaudible] one 45 you know what I'm saying?
Joe,
you saying like why?
I don't understand what you're saying.
I'm just saying and the,
the Nate fight,
it could've went either way but that it didn't happen.
So you can make common in any fights can be big,
but losing does matter.
It then today to the,
to the general population,
it does matter.
It does matter.
But when the fights are the exacts and you could easily see the,
the decision go one way or the other,
like,
you know,
there's fights that you've watched.
We say,
you know what,
the guy got the decision,
but man,
I don't agree with it.
You just said that with Musashi for sure,
man.
It happens all the time.
That's part of the game.
I look at that.
If I,
if I look at a fight like that,
I absolutely want to see that fight again.
I don't care if one guy got a decision from three people that I don't agree
with.
That's fine.
And it,
I guess we're kind of saying the same thing I'm saying Amy fight Conor does is
going to be big.
Well,
the heat,
any fight contract and you can be big,
but I think we both agree that the big money's in the Nate Diaz fight.
Correct.
And I think the smart thing to do the big money would be in the Nate Diaz fight.
Even if they beat him in the second fight.
I really think that,
I disagree with you.
I do because I think Conor is a giant superstar.
He's not going to be less of a superstar and I think Nate would be a bigger
star.
How many times in calculus two worth more money if Nate beat him in the second
fight?
I think Holly,
I think Nate would be a bigger star.
Tony and Conor is about as big biggest fight you can get in the lightweight
division in the UFC history,
Tony in UFC history and UFC history.
Tony Against Carter and that's like Duran vs Leonard.
I don't think it's the biggest fight,
but I think it's not like it's up there.
It's what the among the best lightweight a unification.
Connor's coming off of the Floyd Mayweather hundred people.
No.
Let's say if Nate,
first of all,
any before you rip my head off,
I agree.
Tony and Conor,
100% on these topics.
He's a star in our world,
in the pot,
in the big world.
He's not.
He's a star dog.
Let's say.
Hold on a second.
You think you can go to the gas station right now and go,
hey man,
who's Tony Ferguson?
Depends on the guy who's there.
They'll know
WWE shirt,
shirt on.
It all depends.
You go to the average person and asked them who?
Nate Diaz is.
Way more people going to know who he is.
Then Tony now,
now hear me out.
Joe.
Nate Floyd Mayweather.
Is it still a bigger name?
Then they could do that.
They could do a rematch and have another bid five bigger than Kukui,
but I'm talking about for the UFC.
Fuck everyone outside the UFC.
UFC has millions and millions of fun dates of bigger name all over the world.
All over the world.
There's,
he has the interim belt.
He has to fight him.
I know you're,
why is there a discussion?
There's a discussion in terms of like as a purist,
correct,
but Joe,
what if this was another fight?
Ufc Fan?
I'm right.
As your average UFC fan,
what if Nate fought Barboza or Khabib and beat them?
Think how big that Nate fight would be with Connor.
Then that's a big if though,
the problem with that is Nate's lost.
We're talking about it.
If world,
right now we're talking with Connor lost it,
but we're not right now because we're talking about what the pieces are in play
right now.
Like what?
Wait,
what do we have right in front of,
so we're going to do right now.
So if you're doing it right now,
well,
if you're going by what the fans have voted,
Tony would be the fight that the purists want.
But this is the fans that listen to Ariel Helwani or you.
These are hardcore people do.
In order to make money,
you have to get those people and then you've got to get the people who know it
peripherally.
Well then Nate Diaz,
we polyman nauseas the next fight.
They don't even know Paulie Mala noche here.
They don't until he fights it.
Unless Connor fights in boxing.
That's what I'm saying.
But I mean,
well look,
they've taken all that out of context.
Nate is the bigger fight,
no matter how we paint this picture,
the re the fight you should do.
Is Tony though,
do you think that Paulie Malignaggi versus Conor is a big to get Tony new
sunglasses?
Do you think that Pauline mile and algae versus Connor is a bigger fight in
boxing then Nate versus Connor is an MMA?
I think whatever Connor does is as big as big,
but I think doesn't matter.
I think Nate versus Connor is bigger in MMA then Paulie versus Connor is in.
Yeah,
because cause Paul is not like a Floyd Mayweather
where he's going to get all those boxing fans.
Paul was good and he's a big names on showtime,
but he's not Floyd Mayweather a big,
yeah.
Yeah.
The whole Nate fricking fan base.
You got the Connor fan base,
then you have dubby WME behind that with the hype machine.
Yeah.
And they've severely lightened that.
What a sanctions on weed.
Yeah,
but,
but if you're WME,
you're going,
what are we going to make the most?
Or I'm sorry,
knife.
You're WME.
If you're Connors business planners,
you're going,
how do we make the most money?
It's a McGregor promotion in boxing.
We're gonna make more money doing that.
Fighting Polly.
It's safer than fighting Nate.
Refining.
Totally true.
But if Connor loses two in a row and boxing,
that's severely diminished as a star in MMA come.
What's mmn?
And by the way,
they'll strip him of his belt if he fights another and we got a strip,
they ain't doing shit to him.
He did the USC.
Who's going to do it.
He doesn't want every once you might find it heavyweight,
if you want to do that,
I can do shit to him.
He's too much of a drawl.
But Tony or Nate is a dangerous fight.
Either fight.
Is it Tony?
Tony,
Tony and Nate are more dangerous than fighting poly.
One of the,
Oh,
they did his own GTA post.
What does it say?
Does it say anything?
There's no comment.
I don't think monument.
What does that count?
Yeah.
Oh,
just that.
I mean,
regardless of what was the Tony Ferguson,
Tony has his,
uh,
can,
I told him have been the first one to do it.
I think
Tony Ferguson didn't see,
I don't see one.
Oh,
there it is.
Snapdown city.
No,
that's not it.
Is it?
It is right there.
It's a video or something.
He's running with bears and big bear looking at,
ah,
that's funny.
I'm like,
did he trains up there man?
It's really interesting.
Does he always rent the same place up there is you rent different places,
different houses.
So he just goes like airbnb or something like that for a month and a half.
Exactly.
How many weeks did you stay up there?
Six weeks.
Something like that.
Guy's got phenomenal cardio.
He was so common.
That fight too.
It's like he knew that Kevin was just going to eventually fade out.
Did he know,
did he know about Kevin staph infection?
No,
but I noticed it right when he got in the octagon.
As soon as he got in the octagon,
I'm like,
dude has staff out his chest PSE.
That wanes the way Tony responded to it.
They said,
did you know he had stopped because yeah,
I was trying to punch it using it as a target.
I noticed that I was cold calling it on the,
I can't believe you said something.
What did you think about the fight?
Why didn't you think are,
why did you think?
I wouldn't say,
I don't know.
I do cause I,
if you didn't know with staff,
I was like,
oh fuck.
I knew it was staff.
I like that looks like staff and I said to DC staff enough times to not.
Yeah.
Just say it twice.
Yeah,
I know what staff looks like.
I'm like,
that ain't good.
That's a bad boy.
Yeah.
When he saw staff Mikko he's super screwed already.
It was a tough matchup.
May Have Staff [inaudible] he didn't on antibiotics.
He said he did.
I know he said he didn't.
He said he didn't take the antibiotics cause he didn't want it to wreck his
cardio.
But the staff itself.
Rex You,
I thought Tony looked amazing though.
He did look amazing.
But here's the thing.
When I was saying it and I said to d c I go,
hey man,
I go,
that looks like staff to me.
Is that what works?
Tap and dcs like yeah.
That looks at the tip.
Someone was in dcs ear saying,
don't say anything.
Someone was telling them in the production like don't talk about the staff.
Don't talk when the new skill,
that staff though.
No,
no,
no.
This is before.
Before anybody.
Oh,
I noticed it before anybody.
I noticed it immediately.
He took his shirt off.
He rented the Octagon and Mike that so the truck salt the drawer,
the truck was saying to DC,
don't say anything in DC is like,
yeah,
that looks like staff.
He said it anyway.
What are you going to do?
Well,
he did an interview where he said that they brought it up.
Like someone said it to him and he's like,
no,
I'm going to talk about it anyway.
You have to.
We're just going to ignore fucking staff.
That's huge.
But it's also a huge issue.
Did Tony like wash themselves with bleach and shit afterwards?
Jumped in the shower.
Yeah man.
Did he have to defense soap?
I don't know.
I hope so.
Defense.
So it makes these little wipes too and it's fun.
You can put them on stat.
Look at this size of that fucking staph infection.
I forgot he had them mounted
to,
I forgot to enter the first round.
He escaped though.
Yeah.
Kevin's a talented fucking dude.
Talented young.
Look at the size of that staph infection though.
Jesus Christ.
We're stuff I've ever seen.
That's a huge,
huge pause.
Filled.
Fucking Ho.
How bodied up is that dude?
By the way.
For real jacked.
How would a fuck,
did he make one 55 too?
Cause he looks all of one night.
He looked dead on the scale.
Yeah.
You look like the crypt keeper.
He looked very bad,
but that's a terrible staph infection.
I'll tell you what a Tony Evers,
Connor's a fun match up man.
Sure.
That's a great fight.
Tony has survivability.
He's got crazy and he's great.
He has crazy and in a good way.
He was crazy.
Where are you going to have to kill him?
He can get things off from everywhere.
He can beat you from the ground.
He could beat you standing.
He knock you out.
He throws these weird off angle punches.
He's got a great chin.
The super durable elbows from the guard.
That was what changed.
So town together.
That's where Kevin was in trouble.
Most fighters don't know this.
They think that,
you know in the mount 12 to six is illegal.
Right?
These straight down,
but not in the upside.
Down Mountain is full guard.
Six to 12 there's still the 12 to six was a or on their back.
Those are totally legal.
Mullins fighters still don't know that.
And that'll drone,
which is strange.
They don't throw them.
But you know who,
who was the master of that shit?
Jose Palae land be oh gee.
He was the first Anderson Silva at shoot box.
That was the first one.
Anderson Silva was like his little protege.
Holy pay.
Uh,
Jose paid Landy when he [inaudible] back in the late nineties and valid Tuta
Mecca and all that stuff here.
Knuckle in high school gyms,
they had a rivalry.
Macaca was up.
He still fights now a Macaca was,
um,
a Jujitsu guy and Palae was the Muay Thai guy.
But anytime a cocker would take him down and full guard Paly would put his feet
on his hips and throw those 12 to six from the guard and fucking would brutalize
mutts on power.
It's like you didn't want to take this if that's all you focused on.
Isn't the full bars train a lot of it.
W W W there's,
it's hard to train those,
but we,
you know,
in full guard would say,
remembering always,
always.
You're looking at Benson,
it's part of the game.
Rubber guard and elbows.
They work hand in hand and Jason Day fought Alan Belcher.
Exactly,
exactly.
Jason Day versus Alan Belcher.
He threw like 22 elbows from mission control trucks.
It's part of the system.
If you can't get,
you can't get them in a position where you want them just get to Michigan drone
and throw elbows.
But in that situation in Tony's fight,
Kevin Lee didn't want to stay on his,
but he wanted Tony on the ground.
So when you have a situation like that where Tony's winning the standup,
he wants to stand up,
but you got a restaurant topic now you can put your feet,
you can put your feet on the hips because if Kevin wanted to keep the fight
standing,
let's say he was beating Tony Standing,
then Tony putting his feet on the hips would be bad because then Kevin would
stand up and now we've got to drag them to the ground again.
But since Kevin didn't want to stand,
now you're free to throw those 12 to six from the bottom.
You put the feet on the hips and cause he,
cause Kevin has to put the pressure so it's perfect.
You just hold yourself up and you can't even fire back when you got your feet on
the hip where your knees are blocking the shoulders.
So dudes can't even fire back.
And if you set the pace first,
he's got a block he doesn't have time to throw cause you're coming straight with
those elbows.
You watch that fight.
Uh,
Kevin was,
he was confused with the elbows that threw everything else.
Let's set up the submission.
I'll tell you what's interesting is in the fight with Tony and Conor say that's
next.
If Tony Goes,
you know what,
I'm gonna do my weird movement,
but I'm just going to grapple the fuck out of here.
I don't know how good of a fight you have.
Cause Tony's amazing wrestler.
People don't realize how good of a restless so he could fight for Conor.
I'll tell you that if Todd,
if Tony doesn't want to be good fight,
if Tony Goes,
you know what?
You think of the best standing up.
I think I'm the best.
Watch this.
You have a classic on,
but if Tony Goes,
I'm just going back to my wrestling days,
you're fucked.
It's not great for Connor.
I will say the finishes him.
It's great if he gets Connor to ground,
beats him up and striving for Conor,
for Tony.
It's great.
No matter.
Well,
I think it's a dangerous fight for Conor.
I think it's a very early stage for both guys.
Super Dangerous Rocana.
Tony's the most dangerous guy.
I mean that division by far.
You know,
he's,
he doesn't do anything to add about judging about,
we were talking about the arbitrary three people.
I thought.
I think that's a very flawed system and I think it's completely unnecessary
today.
I think today with access to voting and online and vote,
not a fan vote,
a vote of experts,
a panel of experts.
You get a bunch of Jujitsu,
black
belts that are,
you know,
also a MMA journalists,
a different referees and judges have a panel of like,
you know,
I guess who know what's going on.
How does the Academy Awards work?
I don't know how it works,
but I would assume it's a bunch of people that are experts business.
We're in the business.
Good idea,
Joe.
That's a great idea though.
That's different in the Weinstein case sizes.
Oh man,
it's crazy,
right?
Documentary an open secret.
Watched that show.
I keep hearing about that secret.
It's would good,
right?
Hollywood managers who manage kids.
It's a racket.
Ma'Am.
Did you hear the term kid from strange dude?
Strange things,
strange stranger,
stranger things.
He Day just left.
He just left his manager and they're alleging sexual abuse.
They just left their agency.
If you can find that.
Oh,
and Ben Shirley here,
kid.
Oh,
he's in Benjamin.
Just put it on his Instagram today because Olin is been taking a lot of heat
online because he said that a three year old kid shouldn't be fucking
transgender and people giving him a hard time seeing he's a bigot.
Like are you out of your fucking mind when your top three trends,
stranger things act or dropped agent because of sec accused of sexual assault.
Disney star fall suit.
Jesus Christ.
This is nuts.
Watch an open secret and they tell they go through,
do they pick their people?
It's for free I think on Vimeo.
Yeah.
You can go watch it for free on youtube or something.
You know what a Sturgill Simpson told me.
He said the same thing exists in music,
in music.
There's a bunch of pedos and pet rap music as well.
Business all the way through music that this is about music and movies and TV.
It's about the whole women,
women and kids.
Most of the beers and sometimes dudes,
you know,
Terry Cruz said that he was attacked,
well not attacked.
Some dude grabbed,
grabbed his dick in front of this white famous dude grabbed his dick.
You know who I sold that?
Um,
who was that fucking big time football player that was in that weird movie with
John Travolta.
Howie long,
Howie Long said the exact same shit was happening to him.
Wrapped he lungs.
Dick guys were coming after how we long guys were,
were propositioning him,
trying to tell him this is what you have to do to make it in the movie business
suck Dick or folk who else?
It happened to haul Cogan same thing.
Play.
Yes.
Coating up.
Last call the Logan got proposition by high level movie person that told him
this is how the game is played and did he do it?
I mean that's why he's not in movies or why are you using today?
What you look at guys who are killing it,
super skeptical.
Hip had been coming out.
Now Donald Sterling,
look at these beautiful black bodies.
What does that,
it's something that I heard about before he got in trouble that this is why a
lot of players didn't want to play for him because he was known to bring people
down in the locker room to look at his players showering and whatnot.
Why is everyone so
fucking creepy?
Why can't people be cool?
Be Cool man.
But him and my idea about B,
go back.
Watch your kids.
Watch your motherfucking.
Don't let your kids be around weird fucking agents and take,
don't let your kids get into acting.
Do not let your kids get in position.
But it worked out well.
You know the other thing is like look at what happened with that uh,
Sandusky guy.
That guy was taking care of kids.
Like his whole thing was like,
hey,
I do charitable work with children.
You know,
I do charitable work and I take care of your kids.
Yeah.
I'm just,
I'm just all about helping kids.
It's all about helping kids.
They're our future.
How about Calvin went to summer camp.
Does Dick Sucked my counselor.
I think he got jacked off his friend guys dig.
So
it's funny cause it's,
I'm not advocating any of that.
It's that famous guys,
a famous dude in the UK who died and then they found out what does that,
what's that guys name?
Jimmy Seville.
What he do was like,
he was super famous,
super famous.
He had a big talk show in,
in England.
Benny Hill.
Yeah.
That's the guy.
No Shit.
He fucks look at the picture above him.
Look at that picture above with the red glasses above with the crazy hair.
One more the,
Oh my God.
With that fucking guy.
You should be slapped.
Imagine that guy putting his dick in your mouth.
Is there a documentary on him?
Yeah.
What's that call?
Cause Hey,
she kept this a secret for a long time because this guy was like a,
uh,
a big star over there.
Look at his mother fucking secret.
Like the media,
the people that occurred with him,
like everyone knew that.
Like,
what about the rose that go back to that.
What about law enforcement in the UK?
You know what I mean?
The roos knew Jimmy Seville.
Seville is that,
I say it's Seville.
Documentary is a horrible misstep.
Oh,
Louis Theroux is awesome.
I doubt that he fucked anything up.
That guy makes some of the best fucking documentary's going and he's a month.
It's probably some,
yeah,
someone was a hater.
Exactly.
That is so heavy haters out there.
Think about that.
Think about Donald Donald sub.
No.
Ne.
Yeah.
Suddenly there is a lot of re Jimmy Savile gropes teenager in newly released
Louis Theroux footage.
Oh powerful show.
Have you seen the stuff that Joe Biden,
Joe Biden,
the former vice president do?
There's videos on him like at the White House and taking pictures with kids.
Did you know looking at,
we've seen that.
Really?
I haven't seen,
have you seen that shit?
He's like groping them and shit.
It just think he's super awkward with this guy's running.
When you're untouchable,
when there's no way you're going to get busted for anything.
Murdered child molestation.
Did he don't give a fuck.
He just,
and I don't give a fuck who you are.
You grabbing my kid anywhere appropriate.
There's a lot and he's like,
dude,
I got sick bastard.
It looks like we said that there muffs there and just told her secret.
The problem is you've taken like a screenshot.
I've
heard the audio.
You could hear that.
What he says to these,
what does he say?
Creepy ass shit.
Like get like what?
Like do they just keep,
just keep,
he's taking pictures.
All these kids and he's just like,
ah.
I just whispering in their ear and Oh,
you're beautiful.
You of a big government creep.
Oh,
studio of this.
These are stills,
but there's actually video of this shit,
and this is by the way,
what you're seeing in public,
right?
Yeah.
He don't care.
They don't give a shit not to,
not to deals and care.
It's just,
that's a small version of probably what he's like behind closed doors.
If you're,
if you're a big Hollywood act or maybe you're not and you didn't get sexually
harassed or pissed off right now,
know what I'm saying?
Like what the fuck?
If you're an actress and you worked with Harvey Weinstein,
he never tried to suck his dick.
You're like,
what
the fuck is wrong with my face?
They're really going after him.
That seems weird.
It doesn't seem weird,
dude,
but hell yeah.
You're going after a guy's entire business.
Here's the thing.
He's one of many.
There's gotta be like a bunch of people that ran their business.
That one Weinstein there.
They say like in Hollywood,
like my age,
just like,
oh no.
Yeah,
it's about time you got kind of like,
what the fuck?
Everyone knew this one new contract.
It was in his contract.
The way he had his contracts set up was like they had a certain amount of money
that he would have to pay if he had a sexual harassment claim against him.
It was like,
it was a thing for him.
Like he had so many claims that's like first offense was a hundred thousand
second offense.
My 250003rd offense with $750,000 for third,
fourth offense was a million.
Who would get it written into his fucking contract?
Miramax,
his contract with the Weinstein company like Merrimack.
Explain that contract.
Like they'd have to,
he'd have to pay a hundred thousands yes.
Could,
they're protecting themselves,
show Ras.
When they sacked him,
they go,
okay.
The first time he fucked with one of these guys going to be 100,000 second time
and see it's not just shit.
Yes.
I mean he was,
it was so prominent.
Yes.
It was such a,
she,
it was so known of what he would do.
And look,
even Quentin Tarantino said that he did it to his ex girlfriend.
Quiet Taryn.
Tito said he knew about it.
Yeah,
he did it to Mira Sorvino dude,
and could Harvey Weinstein get any fucking uglier?
He's a kid.
He's got a young ass wise,
so he looks like a troll.
He know what he looks like is a sexual Predator in a Harvey Weinstein movie.
Correct?
Like it was a shitty lifetime movie.
Like,
come on,
let's do a little bit of that legs unrealistic.
He's hideous.
I think.
You know what?
I think he's so bad looking at the girls that he's harassing them.
Most of them bitches are fucking trash anyways.
You know what I mean?
No,
no,
no.
Here's the crisis and distracted.
What about the kids?
Fuck them bitches.
What about the kids that's going on?
I don't focus on that.
Those girls are trash,
just actress.
But here's the question.
Here's the problem was what Whitney told me when he says yes,
she,
she knows her shit.
What she said is she,
there's a lot of girls that aren't saying a word because they did fuck them and
they caught them for parts.
They fucked him for like editing,
of course,
fucked him for a lot of things that Donald Trump.
But that this is like a standard thing that Weinstein would do and women agreed
to it because he was a power from mother fucker that could get them the world
hold up.
However many,
whatever 50 girls are coming out with claims against him,
he's probably fucked 5,000 who aren't coming out.
I think that's probably a real number and ridiculously hot girls we all know
about now what?
I suck his dick to be the next Batman.
Yeah,
probably,
man,
Donald's,
Ronnie,
Darren's you to focus on the kids.
Here we go.
Well that's,
that's certainly an issue,
but that's fuck for parts.
You know what I mean?
Well,
don't you remember Brian Singer?
Remember that guy who is the x men guy?
That guy got busted because some 17 year old boy was saying that he got used by
him at a party and they would pass them around to all their friends and had all
these buoys.
What guy?
Bryan singer and the guy goes,
no,
no x men.
Oh my bet.
X files is talking about the guy with x files x men away.
The famous director.
Oh yeah,
that's the guy.
He's in the movie.
Oh,
an open secret.
I'm sure it's about,
it's about him.
Hold up.
He would that he was just some dude like
here he goes,
look at that.
It's sad.
Turn behind La Party scene that took down Brian Singer.
Like he would have all these like young boys with them and there's a picture of
them at a pool.
It is fucking high.
Larry's.
There's like,
let's drop,
scroll back up.
Look at this picture like look at him and all these young boys that Tim on the
right,
that's him above with the glasses or no,
the one with the arm wrapped around like yellow bass.
The glasses see him with his arm wrapped around.
You've got you wrapped around that boy.
Put his hand on that guy.
The kid's chest.
What the kid looks like.
He's off 16 right?
So there's a picture of him at a party that he threw at his place.
That is hilarious because that party has all these young twinks in a pool and
the pool's lights are red.
Like,
like they butt fuck so much that they just bled out.
And the whole pool became red right there.
Look at that.
Tell me it doesn't look like that.
Fuck man.
That's party a brown
Jesus guys.
Are they all under age?
No,
probably not.
But nothing's wrong with if,
does anyone know how many of them were,
but some of them apparently were under age.
Holy Shit.
It just seems like that's a cock fest.
If you're a young boy and you're trying to be an actor in Hollywood or a singer,
how are you going to avoid that shit?
Look at these fucking parties.
All these guys that hands on each other.
Well,
if the thing about gay guys,
right?
It's like a lot of gay guys like guys that look younger,
they like like cute God.
Twinks he don't,
they call them twinks.
You don't have a lot of hair.
Which really funny because a nd what the fuck's his name from?
Uh,
the guy from a,
that runs bravo.
What was I gonna say?
Oh,
Andy Cohen.
Yeah,
that guy.
He got in trouble for saying twink and he's gay.
Really?
Yeah,
he's King Shit.
He's awesome.
Everything.
Twink is like a thin,
hairless,
like grew young,
young,
skinny
on Jake.
Sorry Darren till walking into the octagon.
Let's actually watch this fight cause he,
I get creeped out.
We all have kids and I feel sick after all that.
It makes it makes me sick.
Jesus Christ,
man.
Yeah.
Well Corey Feldman apparently has been talking a lot about it too.
That was crazy.
It's crazy,
but the question is why is he crazy?
Is he crazy because he was molested.
He meet.
It hasn't say he doesn't name names,
but maybe he will.
If someone said 80% of kids in Hollywood or in the entertainment business have
had some kind of run in with someone trying to molest him,
would you believe it?
Yes.
80% yes.
I would say,
I don't know.
I don't want to give out crazy numbers.
I would say a large number.
I wouldn't be cycling Olympic team wrap up because I think there's legitimate
agents is the legitimate managers and I think Disney has a pretty great record.
They're probably legit,
but those ones don't get any work.
It seems like it celebrates,
like they just hook each other up and they're just looking for,
uh,
they're only going to,
some of them do.
There's definitely predators that are organized.
Definitely no one ever made any advances that you,
Joe.
No,
never.
Nothing.
Not like,
Hey,
come give me a better comic.
Alex John said he got molested in Hollywood when the Alex Jones did.
Alex Jones talked about that probably roofing himself walked into a party and I
remember he was in that movie with Keanu Reeves.
He was in the movie with Kiana re yes.
Yeah.
That one.
Animated Yay.
Wake or something.
Life.
Waking life.
Yeah.
It was a great mood.
He was in that he was driving.
This was before anybody knew who Alex was and I was friends with him even back
then.
But he,
uh,
they animated him ranting,
driving down the street and see you play some of that place.
There it is.
Rolling across the picket line,
lay down,
lay down Gi.
We saw it all through the 20th century and now the 21st century.
It's time to stand up and realize that we should not allow ourselves to be
crammed into this rat maze.
We should not submit the him and I station.
I don't know about you,
but I'm concerned with what's happening.
I'm concerned with the structure.
I'm concerned with the systems of controls.
Oh my life and those to control it even more.
I want freedom.
That's what I want.
And that flips.
You should want
my favorite all time.
Alex Jones Club,
he keeps getting mad swearing and he says,
I apologize,
I shouldn't have said that.
And he just can't easily like a hole,
but a compilation of him frequently.
So he did that one movie and got molested instantly.
Even even though he was animated,
they molested his,
that's what he said on his show.
He said it was during that movie bus is at least 10% crazy though.
You agree?
Right?
What was that?
He's at least 10% crazy.
He's a but on the stuff that he reports about,
uh,
85% correct.
That's probably a good number.
At least 80 right?
80% he's talking about some that's probably legit.
Occasionally he goes off the rails and that hurts them.
But that's okay.
You can't be 100% right.
But the problem is he's always looking for conspiracies that might not exist and
then people can discredit it because of the misses.
You gotta take some swings and hit a home run.
You know it's true.
When you're making all these accusations,
you know,
against criminals,
a couple of them are not going to stick.
You know,
and you might be wrong about a couple of murders here and there,
but they're still murderers.
So we should focus on the fact that Alex Jones on Info wars,
if you,
if you'd think that's a fake news station to get,
then you've been brainwashed because that's where most of the truth is coming
from.
It's coming from Info wars,
my man and the mainstream media,
the mainstream media is trying to convince you that info wars is a hundred
percent fake news when they're the fake fakeness,
bro.
My man,
cowboy needs Propecia.
Does it?
Yeah.
A little bit.
It looks like is his,
and see a cowboy.
Really.
You'll see it.
I see.
I love cowboy got messed up hair.
I like to see a cowboy part of that.
I thought that was funny.
Brendan.
See Ya.
Oh maybe no one has a receding hairline like that.
I do my shit.
It's way worse.
Look at mind.
No it is not.
I like the new a hairstyle you rocking.
I like that.
Shaved on the stock.
You look like you look like a guy from fury.
You seen that movie?
You copy freshly haircut.
I do this all the time but when you see me at grows out a little bit.
But once every two months I cut my hair.
We've got a big day tomorrow so yeah,
cause you're here.
Hell yeah.
I still have no Denny's doing combat.
Get to tomorrow.
Oh Shit.
Is He really who we are?
I put together a special match.
It's an alternate match for the four man tournament that boogey man's doing.
Boogie man is doing combat.
You'd get to Oh shit.
Think about that shit.
And then Denny is fighting another black belt and just an alternate single
match,
which is going to be like a little super fight.
So let me tell you what Vinny shoreman says about this Guy Darren till,
because Vinny shoreman is a very high on him.
You know,
Vinny is a big time,
uh,
Moitai commentator.
He knows a lot of shit about Moitai tills.
A monster till was beating men at 15 years of age rent to Romanian one an eight
man tournament,
fought two fights with a broken foot at 17.
Started training odor.
There are Collin heroin from Kabuni.
Uh,
a guy who was a super Thai boxer himself and now successful MMA gym knows calm
for 30 years at top coach Til til super determined.
Lived in Brazil too.
And he's a real rags to riches story.
He got,
he got stabbed,
he had to go to Brazil because he got stabbed twice.
Guy Right here,
he got stabbed in Liverpool.
His coach was like,
Yo man,
if you want to be successful,
you need to move to Brazil.
Move to Brazil.
One undefeated there.
Just cause it's so much shit.
And Liverpool stabbed another party.
People are so fucking crazy.
Yeah,
it's just,
you know,
he's running with a rough lot of stabbings going on.
There's,
I saw crazy statistic where the stabbing is through the roof,
right?
And no one's banner nine when it has a lot of stuff.
Get stabbed and shot.
Well,
if you ban knives,
how are you going to cut your steak?
All right,
here we go.
Darren cowboys.
Here we go.
Scissors wrap people big till is first of all he's the legit welterweight and
Donald just swung and miss with a leg kick and Donald's a slow starter man.
Tills it's a trouble fight tells.
Got some good deals.
Oh Donald went for the take down.
Tilt it down.
Defenses.
Good.
Very good.
Till defended such a dangerous,
we could have pulled guard right there.
It tells a super high level kickboxer.
You see good distance control already.
Oh Shit.
He just tagged him.
He clipped him.
Not,
not clean.
You're here.
How?
Till got the,
Oh my God.
Whoa.
Got To come forward at Donald.
If you're going to beat him.
Katelyn,
sit back and get comfortable.
Well,
he's a bigger fight or to look up.
Oh Shit Dude.
Oh Shit.
Just Dang them this.
This is a bad thing.
He's got to shoot and pull guard here.
Yeah,
this is a bad fire guard.
Oh my God.
Something tagged.
He doesn't move his head,
man.
The cowboys firing back cowboys not out of it.
You got to remember all the times cowboys been in trouble in the past.
He's a slow start and then once he gets going he's trouble.
This guy legitimately might be the best striker.
He falls and there is chance right here.
Jump on his back.
Ooh,
we've got a good fee.
Get ups,
Hillman.
You know what I'm saying?
Like you felt the in some weird Brazil fights.
I'm sure it's been taking down a bunch.
Could defense back up to his feet.
I don't know anything about this guy.
Fuck I d I didn't either at first and I talked shit about him.
He lashed out at me.
I did my research like,
Oh fuck,
this kid is an oh,
you're talking about this main event.
I was talking shit about them.
Could tell you the body.
What's his name again?
Darren till Darren till.
Fascinating story.
[inaudible] pull stories like Donald has been doing a lot of other shit too.
Hasn't he been doing a movie?
A movie?
Yeah,
we clipped him TV show,
low co from my upper cut there.
And then you got young till who's a monster who's just,
this is all he's thinking about the biggest options life.
Nice Jab.
I tell it's looking very good and good.
Good distance control on the feet.
How relaxed he is first.
First main event is crazy and he's fucking,
I can't get over how big he is.
Oh Dude.
He's tuning cowboy up
and he just doesn't respect cowboys stress.
Hammonds are low.
Look at how low his hands or he doesn't really give a shit.
Well you gotta think cowboy striking is good for MMA,
but at the level that you know you're talking about like glory or you know,
lion fight like real high level Moyie Thai guy.
How far did he go?
Well Darren Walker was just saying what I miss that tournament in Romania.
Oh fuck that.
Vinny shoreman who's a bit,
I'm trying to watch this and talk at the same time.
Vinny shoreman oh that's a good kick to the body cowboy.
Vinny shoreman is very high on this guy.
He says he's a very legit Moy Thai fighter,
like the,
the people who were in the know and the business are super hundred until super,
super.
You're seeing it here just from this distance control and his footwork and
movement.
Like every time cowboy,
he's trying to kick him.
He's a slide in a way at,
he's beautiful,
right jab too.
And he's a southpaw too.
And his,
oh shit.
He's landed straight left and he sat up,
land that upper cut.
He's done that twice to cowboy cowboy.
She's ducking down cowboys getting lit up.
Man,
he's getting lit up,
but he's not having much success.
You know,
if you're the UFC though and you're,
you're looking for,
you know,
fresh stars and new blood,
this is what you do and that,
yeah,
it is what you do.
And Cowboy is the guy that will fight anybody anywhere flies to fucking Poland
to find this kid,
you know,
and said,
I didn't watch any footage on them.
I don't know shit about him.
I heard he's a good standup.
Good.
I love to strike,
which is why we love cowboy,
but it's a double edge sword in.
Yeah,
well especially is when you're a big name like cowboys,
a huge name.
So for cowboy to fight,
this guy who is arguably one of the best strikers he's ever fought and he didn't
really look into a much,
but it does nothing for cowboys.
So you beat them to go?
Yeah,
he'd be the guy we'd never heard of.
You lose whole.
We just got hurt.
He just got hurt.
Darren just lit him up.
This fuck it.
Oh Bro.
This kid cowboys trouble knees till cowboys in big trouble.
Oh Shit.
This is,
that's it.
That's it.
How I just got stopped first round smashed.
Ran through what?
A story down this got ran through a story on tender here.
He just ran through cowboy.
Just about ran through him.
Through him?
Yeah.
Just smashed him.
Smashed early.
Last.
Just smashed him.
This guy has the ability to maybe,
you know,
contend for the belt.
Oh,
hunter hunter is taken out of his side.
His only 24 it's 24 with that extensive of a striking and he just made,
he just turned into a fucking star,
at least in our small group of MMA.
This is on fight pass.
There might prop 40,000 people watching less talking about it might not even be
40,000 but this is bigger than that.
Like however,
watching this,
you put a youtube video taking a piss.
What is,
it gets more beautiful.
We have 40,000 watching on here.
Yeah,
we're beating them.
But then when it sits for 10,000 remember those days?
Yeah,
115 hundred but when it can look at that elbow,
we landed on him.
Jesus Christ.
Oh Dude.
He t tuned cowboy up.
I mean,
that is just an absolute beating.
I hate seeing it for cowboy like,
and this is the reason why Kelby so big,
but then it's also like it,
you're fucked you man,
because you're never going to be world champion fighting like this.
Well,
it's also,
cowboy has had a few of these fights recently.
Mosfet all beat the shit out of him.
You know,
the Robbie Lawler fight,
his last fight was a rough fight.
Well some people,
you know,
I don't think Calvin win that fight,
but it was a controversial fight to get back to the judges.
You know,
some people think Calloway Roseville,
I think cal,
they lost that fight.
I think he'd lost too because especially like Robbie really came on strong in
that last round.
The first round.
If you have ten eight it'd be a draw.
But cowboy is shaking his head,
his nose is smashed and we lost three in a row brother.
Yeah,
that's a,
that's a rough go.
And your cowboys age lost three in a row and just got marked by a young kid.
A 24 year old kid just lit him on fire.
24 year old stud though.
This is not just some random fucking,
yeah,
well that's why you don't fight randoms and Poland though,
right?
Well as it should be a 55 he's a 55 or,
I mean he's one of those guys that went up to one 70 like design hills.
And generally that doesn't work though.
It doesn't work though.
Not,
I mean,
not that often.
How you were just talking about Kevin leak like cobble has killed himself at 55
but he was dominated at 55 cowboy never champion.
He got close to a belt at 70 they did 55 well,
I mean he lost the belt at 55
we have to worry about how the cowboy show ends because cowboy getting stopped
like that and this fight like you gotta wonder how many more of those we're
going to see and what,
what does that,
what tolls that going to take on cowboy because of that style that he has.
You know,
because of the fact that he's willing to fight anybody and because of the fact
that he spends his money like water,
you know,
game,
you play the law,
it's cowboy.
Like that's the persona he has your cow.
We fighting went anywhere and then once I stop,
I know,
that's what I'm saying is you got to worry about how this,
how this story ends.
Because when you 34 you don't get younger,
you just get older.
But he's still a name.
So how many more fights will they give them?
Ooh,
look at this.
Look at that.
That fucking right left Combo.
He just landed on him.
We should back this up and watch it again because he tuned you.
I'd love to hear what Tim is saying.
Look at this.
Oh no,
that was it.
Right?
Those wicked.
I can't get over how fucking big this kid is,
man.
For that weight class.
Yeah.
Gimme some volume.
Jeremy.
He's given Cowboy Lotta love.
He's amazing for that as well.
Dan Hardee speaks English too.
He knows what he's saying.
You know English,
English from England.
Mike Perry,
he'll jump in that fucking cage.
She will fuck my guy.
Perry platinum.
Mike Perry,
he's a tough guy.
He's a knockout artists.
He knocked out,
um,
uh,
Jake Ellenberger,
the Joanne Jo band.
I'm out.
Struck him till would piece him up,
I think.
No,
he's crazy man.
He is crazy.
But skill wise,
he's nowhere near.
Not even on the same planet.
Not even the same part of the yard he does is really box.
Yeah.
Well he's an animal.
I mean,
Mike Perry is a fucking animal.
No doubt.
Found them all because he or she is a strong guy.
He's got some serious power.
He's from here.
Paris from Florida.
Yeah.
Strong with serious power.
But he's in he's way out class.
When he fights like a really good striker like job answer was foot work.
They just,
they just avoid the big shot and just pick them apart.
Yeah.
But if you play that game you will not get a fucking Pluto.
This is a different guy though.
This Darren till is it?
This is a different guy.
Shoreman was saying,
you know what?
I wish the remote right here.
Run that bench.
Yeah.
Run that bitch back.
Let's watch this again.
I wish they would a enough,
they can't cause you need the fight on fight pass by.
I wish they would air it like tomorrow on Fox sports so you can so till he gets
like more recognition because how many people are going to see this beat down?
That's a good question.
But the thing is like if they aired on Fox sports,
Fox sports,
own it,
then how does that work?
You do got a Brazilian flag with his English flag.
Yeah.
That's him there for a while.
Training.
That's why eight years,
I think allow man total eight years.
So he was like a little kid when he went over that.
It's so nuts.
These 24 years old and this is already this good God damn.
Which this dome.
Come on man,
that was so crisp.
What show did he come up on?
All right,
I'll ask me.
I don't know.
It's only going back to this,
if any just texted him.
He says,
I told you he is special.
Well,
but a lot of odds makers barely had Calloway is the favorite.
Callo was like a minus one 20 so there's a reason for it,
you know?
Yeah,
but people in the know no tills a fucking monster.
Boom.
Crazy shit man.
It's inserting call out Mike Perry after that.
Maybe just once he another wind,
but my career is ramped in Jujitsu.
I don't know.
It's a good question.
Okay.
Take down the fence.
Brazil.
Yeah,
he's there alone.
He also speaks Portuguese.
I'm sure.
So have them fight Brazil.
That'd be interesting,
right?
Yeah.
I think the Brazilians would totally love them.
Look at this shit.
You could just put up some stuff from your phone.
Yeah.
Let's,
uh,
let's watch the fight again.
I'm trying to rewind.
Fucking cowboys knows everyone.
I think you don't want to,
you can.
Yeah,
But you have to use the remote and click on it and then scroll backwards.
Just doing that.
Is it because it's streaming?
Yeah,
I think so.
Cause it's still going on.
It's not really.
Yeah.
Tell boys nose looks fucked.
It looks fucked.
Yeah.
Knows I feel for the dude.
Yeah,
me too.
Is it my phone?
Yeah,
it is my phone.
I love cowboy.
Just fight like that,
you know.
But it's what we were saying.
It's like how does that story end?
How does anyone's story?
Yeah.
But how does this story and is very different than how's the George Saint Pierre
Story and George St Pierre retires now he's coming back to fight and Bisping the
cowboy stories different because cowboy was never the champion and he loves this
rough and tumble life.
You know,
he loves the fact that he can just,
you know,
get on a flight and fight in Poland and gotten kicked this young kid's ass.
But
when it doesn't work out like this,
like you just made a star,
like he led a dude become a star off them.
Like for guys like us and people that a visit the websites look at that fucking
straight one,
two man and that elbow in the clinch,
he is setting them up with a lot of shit to like throw in the straight left but
then turning it into an upper cut.
Yeah.
Ooh God damn.
It's wrapped it on him too.
I wish we had another angle of that.
Ooh,
it's weird cause it's fights.
Before this you would see a stamp.
Sannup is good,
but he was winning by decisions who want a split decision.
He had a draw really
maybe maybe knocking people's socks off early on.
Maybe
cowboy had a terrible training camp or maybe the jet lag is fuck thing is just
realizing he's just that comfortable.
Yeah,
he's that good.
He's 24 and he's also realizing,
look,
you're just watching his movement in this.
I'm not saying cowboy had a bad training camp.
I'm saying this kid's a motherfucker.
The way he landed that uppercut,
the way he landed,
that one too,
that jab left like my Perry.
Ask him for this fight.
It's like,
I guess he's there.
It'll still called him out.
I know.
It's just once a year item.
No,
because he's a name Mike Perry's name God from Calloway to Perry though.
Good fight.
Fun Fight.
Let him like,
he's going to fight a brawler.
Let him show his skills.
I mean,
I would think that's a good fight for him.
Look,
this dude dude's just standing up credit matchup for him.
Yeah,
it's a great matchup for her.
It has a,
a fight already though.
Who's he?
Gotta fight?
Um,
I forget,
but I'm pretty sure he has a,
a matchup already.
Interesting.
Very interesting.
Just a difference in the level of technique.
You know what till can do,
he can do everything.
You know,
he's not just a guy that just wades in and throws haymakers.
I mean,
he's like very,
very technically proficient besides him.
But as you look,
you could get killed.
He could get fucking knocked out.
Mike Perry can knock out anybody you fuck up and you zig when you should have
that fight.
That's it.
Fucking tough fight for him too.
That's a great Santiago and no Byo.
Is Doug just speed?
Uh,
uh,
Gunnar Nelson.
It was with the finger poked with still.
Yeah.
That was a fucked up.
It was more than one finger poke.
Well you beat them by finger.
Yeah.
Knocked when they be on by finger poke boy.
He stopped him.
Yeah.
The fingers were so fucked.
So fucked up.
And when you see the replay of the finger pokes,
you're like,
wait a minute and almost looks like he threw it as a part of his combination
four times in that fight.
Gunner ever get him to the ground.
No Gun.
I got fun early on from the eye posts.
If you don't watch it,
like in slow Mo,
if you just watch it,
oh my God.
Kevin looks like shit.
He's getting rocked.
What's going on here?
You go back.
Watch in slow mo and it's just I poke poke against the cage.
Poke motherfuckers doing upper cut like that.
Fucking poke both eyes.
Here's the stoppage again.
Dang.
Oh Man.
The elbow already did it.
Did it.
I
mean he just beat the shit out of a man and cowboy just crumpled.
When was the last time you saw cowboy and do this?
And this is like dos Anjos days maybe.
Yeah.
Dosa doubled.
Pedis was just a kick to the body,
but he crumbled.
You know what I'm saying?
Like I see my competition Raf man,
Ralph.
Heartbreaking.
Yeah,
I'm fucking real heartbreaker man.
But for that kid,
you know that's a god who was a great story.
Good kid too.
And obviously you've got to build stars.
That's how you do it.
I mean,
not a fight path with yes.
That's what happened.
Right?
Not on $5.
That's not the way to do it.
Give out the numbers on five paths.
Like did they tell you?
Nope.
They didn't even tell you.
They're like
no numbers.
Smart mode.
Right.
Why give it up when you don't have to give it out?
If you killing it.
So,
okay,
let's look at this man.
I mean,
Shit Dude.
Bisbing versus GSP.
Now I'm hearing that that's not selling well.
Like the square garden from what I've heard too.
It's not doing great.
Hmm.
That's unfortunate.
It doesn't make it less and it just,
you know,
I just went,
it's not doing great GSP GSP versus Bisping.
He's not doing great.
Not like you'd think though.
Here's the thing though,
if you really stop and think about it,
that was four years ago was the last time you fought Johnny Hendricks.
The people that are into the UFC now diff post Ronda Rousey and post Conor
Mcgregor,
like the casual fans hosts Lesnar the hot,
the hardcore fans like you and I,
we're gonna go,
we're gonna Watch that fight for sure.
Like,
okay,
I'm gonna see what Bisping looks like.
You know,
fighting a guy like George St Pierre was smaller than him.
God has taken four years off.
Bisping's got this opportunity to make a shitload of money.
And then George George,
how's George going to look?
It's a tough moment for years.
It's a tough sell.
Even for the hardcore fans like pulling all,
that's a great fight.
Fight.
Bisping and GSP is going to be a great fight.
I'm looking forward to it for sure.
Keep even,
even now people keep,
they don't give Bisping the respect.
I agree.
He keys,
he's not going to get it.
Even if he beats GSP,
that's the problem.
He took four years off.
He,
he's a seven year.
He might and it doesn't matter.
It doesn't sell 2 billion.
Fuck that dude's that.
The casual fans,
fuck them.
Just,
just we got enough.
You can't run a business like that Eddie.
No,
you don't care.
All we care about is the matchups.
That's a good matchup.
No,
you don't know it.
Not work like,
but we don't run the business.
So for us,
Eddie's right.
I agree with Eddie.
As long as they're putting in these fights on,
I think it's a great fight.
Right.
So you'd have to,
would rather watch a GSB has taken four years off fight for the middleweight
title than him fight a guy who's an actual champion,
85 like I don't mind,
I'm in no hurry.
That's not what I'm saying.
First of all,
Whitaker's injured and you can't fight right now with her care as a pretty
serious tear his knee ligament.
So that's one thing.
This is also an opportunity for Bisbing who's been in the game forever to make a
shitload of money.
I liked that.
I liked Michael.
I liked the fact that Michael is an opportunity to make a fuck load of money
here.
I like this.
No,
don't need it to sell him old man.
That's why you do what you wanted to make.
But if you wanted to make money,
it has said,
yeah,
but I'm not in the business of selling paper views.
Well I'm in the business so we don't want to speak.
You just said you wanted him to make a lot of money.
Well,
he's going to make a lot of money.
Either way he's going to make more money in this fight.
I'll guarantee there's some sort of a guarantee like pay view points where you
make your money like your re your life changing monies paid for viewpoints as
mighty mouse.
As Jon Jones asked Connor Mcgregor,
I'm sure,
but don't you think that George Saint Pierre is at least going to do half a
million pay per view buys maybe more.
I like to think so.
Heartbreaking.
If he doesn't.
I like to think he's going to do at least a half a million.
Make sure this thing about 700 stuff's weird.
Me Out,
man.
This weird shit that he's doing,
whether they're touching things with moving things and touch things with his
feet.
Have you seen how Jack d looks?
Looks jacked.
He looks super swollen.
What if he pisses hot?
He'd,
I don't think he cares.
I think if he's just one and done,
he's like,
hey,
I fought whenever I'm gone.
See Ya.
I did not know.
And when you,
when you get popped again after money,
when money taken away,
25% yeah.
They take some of your mind only 25% though.
Even if you won.
Yeah.
Look it Lesnar my bat hunt 25% here you go.
Gimme this.
Yeah.
I'm,
I'm very curious about this fight.
Very curious.
Yup.
I'm listening.
I'm balls deep in me.
I think it's a,
it's a fun fight.
Not The fight that
take people down these days too.
It is.
The GSP was taken everyone down five years ago.
This means it's up.
Damn tough to take.
The dance gets it.
It's going to be a little harder.
I don't,
I'm not sure the GSP is going to be able to take people down like you did five
years ago.
I'm not sure.
I'll be right there.
This matchup.
It's all rights by nowhere near the best fight on the card.
You look at that card.
It's a fucking heater.
Do you think that's a recent picture of George?
No,
not at all.
I think it is because I think he looks like his gun.
It's a little soft.
Oh,
that's fair.
Yeah.
All right.
A little bit like,
look,
we just saw Kevin Lee.
He's thicker than a snickers down their,
yeah,
Jesus Christ thick.
That's Johnny Hendrickson.
That big kind of heavy,
like around the middle.
Yeah.
Eating a lot,
but there's a,
there's a big difference between that and Kevin Lee.
Right.
Kevin leave was g,
g G.
G.
G jacked jacked Rick when he was on top of that picture of him on top of Tony
when he was dropping bombs on them,
jacked,
jacked.
George does not look that good,
but then again if he's clean,
which she kind of has to be,
have to be,
I think he's 35 now.
He's not young.
How old was George?
I mean he's 35 you can be in great shape at 35 but really it completely helps if
you were super active for a long time.
Are we looking at the tip of his Dick in that picture?
What's that all about?
He has a fat take if that,
so why don't you guys Photoshop that out please.
I want to look taking that picture.
That's all I can see you Mike Perry here.
First of all,
send that fucking jacket in a time machine back to the eighties have that
jacket,
but crank the volume up and this Jamie,
let's hear what he has to say.
He's going to drop some f bombs again.
It good
is,
and we got assigned to paperwork and we're going to make it happen.
I'm pretty sure that it's going to go down.
I look forward to it,
but I got work to do first with Santiago positive you in Winnipeg,
Canada.
He sounds like a rapper.
Yeah.
Well it's got a tattoo above his eyebrow.
It feels like it's about to drop some sick beat.
Yeah.
You look good against Donald Donald Cerrone,
Donald,
the cowboy,
the cowboy that that wins fights.
That was Donald that that shows up at.
And uh,
I wasn't,
I wasn't happy with Donald's performance.
What is it?
American
Darrin didn't get a tough finder tonight.
He got someone who gave up in the first round,
but that doesn't,
you know,
that that's not what was done.
Donald.
Did it look great.
They should keep Mike Perry off.
Microphone from now on.
Go.
Hey.
I love it.
Enjoying limp biscuit.
What does that mean?
Well,
it sounds like a white rapper.
Do you feel like that one towards the top 10 do you want an even playing field
with your,
did you still feel like you're ahead of him?
My parents got a great record.
I'm number 15.
I don't know where that puts him on the rankings,
but rankings don't matter then
it never mattered since I've got here.
That's fair.
My right,
my left hand,
he wants to box.
I look forward to any MMA fighter that won a box with me.
Santiago punks in Libya was going to be the first example of that.
Right.
What's that guy's name?
The guy with the bow tie.
I know,
but he seems scared.
I'm scared to say anything.
This makes me uncomfortable.
He's heavy handed as well.
Yeah.
I'll get myself and my deep in my training camp.
Focus on,
on,
uh,
the things,
the aspects of Santiago's game and do what I gotta do to,
to,
uh,
focus on him and beat him.
And very similar.
I'll get there until,
what's that face?
Very similar style.
Similar at all,
sir.
Guess they both throw punches.
Correct.
I look forward to a man.
I can't wait to do it.
And I looked up,
skyrocket myself off this kid undefeated record.
I'm ready to take that on from that board.
It's weird talking about that fight when you have a huge fight
for
him.
Rocking back and forth.
I like him.
That mother fucker hits a haul truck.
He's like,
he reminds me a lot of limits.
He's just a fucking nightmare if you get hit by him.
But if you can avoid it,
it's an easy game plan.
Jake Ellenberger fight man.
When he caught Jake with a big fucking deal.
But that November 4th garde,
first of all,
Cody Garbrandt dill shawl,
fucking ridiculous.
Fiery.
Very interesting.
[inaudible] rose.
Ridiculous,
ridiculous dude.
Wonderboy Mazda doll fun.
Love it.
Then the big rates back,
big rigs back near the steakhouse.
He might make weight.
I can't promise you,
but he's back.
He's at Jackson's now.
That's like,
that's like don't move into Florida when you're older.
It's just what people do when they get older.
Tired.
I'll be like,
I'll try out Jackson Jackson's go to Albert shirt.
I'm going to try real camp.
Yeah,
let's try this out.
It was an interesting,
listen to what Johnny Hendricks was saying about training in Texas.
He was like,
I gotta be careful when I spar with people cause if I go do ho too hard then
they won't come back to you got to find a real camp.
Yeah,
per watt can.
He can't,
but everybody go too hard.
You're fucked up.
But he saying Aka and let me know how that goes.
So that's what he was saying.
He was saying finally I can go to Jackson's and I'm getting pushed.
He's like,
where I am in Texas,
I'm,
I'm just not getting pushed.
He left,
he left that team take down.
Remember they had some gnarly dudes there.
He left them.
There was a lot of shit going on with that though.
You know how that worked?
Yeah.
He had a weird deal when they're like 20% of all the shifts.
Oh yeah.
They took like the game,
a salary and then they took like half as money.
Like they,
but the thing is the guy put a lot of money in everything.
So I see his perspective too.
It's like they put together a training facility.
They put,
they hired all these coaches,
they had all this stuff going on.
They paid for everything.
They gave him a salary and then when it came time,
you know to for that investment to pay off,
they wanted half the money and I don't know how they,
how they worked it out.
Johnny Hendricks on,
you're a national champion from Oklahoma state and someone's like,
hey,
we're going to vet.
You wouldn't take 50% right?
Fuck you man.
Well I think what happened was,
you know,
once you started getting that world championship money,
that's probably one of the 5% then he opened the big rig steakhouse,
which God blesses the problem.
That's the bigger problem.
Opening a restaurant is like notoriously one of the worst investments you could
ever make.
Restaurant Lodge celebrities go under.
Jim's are bad,
right?
But gyms don't have the same kind of overhead that a restaurant does and the
dynamics of arrest,
they just don't go well.
And if you get a couple of bad reviews,
you don't bounce back unless it's a Mexican restaurant.
You don't have to have a clean restaurant.
If it's Mexican food,
not making marine,
you don't have to be nice.
You know like we show up to El Torito.
What was that place on Fairfax and is it not?
El Torito is that place and lost.
Bonnie knows Benito Benito.
Benito burritos show up and it's like little Taco shop and there's a Mexican guy
in the back.
He's making a burrito and you said hey.
And he looks over and he goes,
hey,
can I get two the sodas?
And the guy just kind of looks at Unis like waves at you kind of just nods at
you and you're like cool,
there's going to be a great place.
That was a white guy that did that.
They'd be shut down.
If it's good,
I'll put up with it.
So with photos is 24 hours a day.
Oh is it on Beverly?
On Beverly and Fairfax Him.
I'm hungry.
So going,
he called me cracker.
Make my breed on.
Ah,
it's so good.
That place is off the charts girly and it's a 24 hour joints.
So it's like a late night comedy store.
Chicken burritos.
You'll go there at one o'clock in the morning.
You might wait 20 minutes in line cause he's a bare ass line.
There's a Mexican restaurant in the valley.
They'd close down for a week because they got shut down for a rodent
infestation,
frozen the newspaper and everything.
As soon as they were when we were waiting in line backstreet boys tickets or
something.
You know what I mean?
Can we ate there like yesterday?
We don't give a shit.
Yeah,
they closed down the kitchen cause they had too much.
Too many rodents.
Amen.
If it's good food too,
I'll put up with it,
man.
I'll put up with a lot of stuff.
Chinese food,
same thing.
They don't have to be nice.
You know when you go to Chinese food and there's like,
there's a big group you guys are like mean and shit then,
but if it's white all you can't do it.
Why you gotta be high?
Of course you have to be really nice if you're white,
you know what?
I need to get back to it.
There's a fucking Thai place that rob came and took me to in Thai town.
You know where Thai town is?
I guess it's on Hollywood or sunset sunset or Hollywood.
Hollywood,
Hollywood.
When you go east,
if you go east on Hollywood,
there's a whole section of lets you know where Trump is right across the street
from jumbos clown room.
You know that's strip club jumbos that's,
everybody was making fun of it.
I don't know anything about cerebral palsy.
I hear you.
Me Neither.
But that's what I hear.
But it's right across the street and it's like legit late sonic Thai food.
So good.
Legit.
I know you've eaten there Eddie.
I know we've eaten there to get the Hollywood boulevard.
Oh,
you a toy?
No,
not that place.
That's on sunset.
You're talking about,
you're talking about the good spot too.
Which what street?
Further down.
I'd been Hollywood and it's,
it's on Hollywood patio.
Maybe it's on the [inaudible] side.
Hollywood boulevard on the north side.
You know what it is,
you know when you go down Hollywood and it goes,
you almost have like that arch that you pass through that takes you into like
Thai town arch.
Isn't there an arch?
My imagination are Thai town sounds off.
That's the lunch.
The one with the yellow.
Look at this.
Fuck.
This chick wants to be black,
white chick from Maury.
Povich steady.
Eddie was talking about her.
Fuck her.
Want to be black?
Well,
look at them today.
Is that video of this?
Can you play a video called
nonsequitor?
By the way,
Jamie just pulled it up.
Both Jamie said,
give me some volume.
Does she talk black?
Yeah,
the Maury Povich show.
Can you change your race to take a look?
He's still killing it.
My next guest,
Martina,
when she was a quietly making millions,
this is Martina,
desperately wanted it to look like Pamela Anderson.
Oh,
okay.
So Apple,
here's in several cosmetic surgeries.
Martina transformed her lumps and do this.
Oh,
the crowd in jars
go.
Martina made worldwide headlines,
shocking transformation,
chemical injections and body modification.
Martina now considers herself a black woman.
I want it to look like a Barbie.
Oh,
she's not American aids
and what beautiful body.
Look at that like.
The Barbie was long,
blonde hair and long necks,
but we got breasts.
Martina began to dream about having plastic surgery.
Do look like her idol.
Pamela Anderson.
Oh my God,
that's crazy.
Nothing like that.
We'll look at those.
Fucking basketball began.
That's what it is.
Well,
the teeth makes sense.
Wow.
Whoa.
I got married,
so the biggest titties I've ever seen,
they're so stupid.
Look and chest to sit down.
I also had delightful sec.
It gets long.
Bobby [inaudible] thousands of dollars on plastics or two.
Martina was ready for her most shocking transformation.
I got three injections in the valley to change my skin color.
What?
Snow and the broker owner of a skin
today.
Martina says
she is black.
Black,
black.
Look at her hair.
Do you think that's fake Tan to just went over it?
Didn't did it
a lot of fake.
I've never seen him fake Tan.
Look at her.
Look at those stupid tits.
Those tits are distro preposterous.
God,
we are sick
people.
Some white face.
Does she use the n word?
I've heard of people doing fake things on Maury before.
Tricking them.
Just making up a story,
so hold on.
But those chicks can't be fake.
What is she saying?
Hold on.
Maybe they can be okay.
Myself.
What I also liked to do.
Photos work on the photos.
I didn't see if you have the cuffs of Pamela Anderson.
Yeah,
photos would be much more.
That's awesome.
So you want her to look like Pamela Anderson because you like her curves.
Yeah.
And so then you became what you thought was Pamela Anderson and little bit more,
but now
it goes over our shoulders and arms.
That's how they do it in movies.
Yeah.
Think could be.
Sure.
It doesn't look like it.
Was it Sandra neck,
black girls,
rock black.
God's wrong.
Black slacks,
girls,
rock girl.
Oh girl.
Plots of land when he's,
I'm like,
yes.
Yes.
I get my first look at that.
So dark that somehow I got the liposuction as a form.
I want to see her boyfriend.
Right.
Fucks
retirees.
Browse forward to the boyfriend.
Maybe there's a boyfriend in there.
No,
there is no boyfriend.
Are you sure?
Look Darker.
There's no what?
She says,
there's no boyfriend.
Three injections in the belly and after the first boyfriend shown his face shot.
But today's security,
Martina,
what the fuck you're,
Yup.
Oh No,
no,
no.
Oh No.
I know you have to learn a lot.
Yeah,
I see
your skin is black,
but you're not a black person.
But here's the thing.
All people came from Africa originally,
like the only reason why people have white skin at all because he moved to
colder climates.
It was more cloudy and we didn't have vitamin D.
So you're,
you basically like a solar panel for vitamin D.
That's what white people are.
That's why people in England are so fucking Pale because it's always raining and
that's exactly what it is.
Like everyone came from Africa.
All human beings came from Africa.
So she's not really black because that's not really her natural skin color
sheet.
But dude,
that is the greatest thing you've ever said for mankind.
She's not applying to a lot of reasons.
It's a Turd giant problem that people have.
This idea of race,
like the only reason why people look different,
it's because we moved to different climates.
Like everyone comes out of the same thing.
Sort of like all dogs come from wolves.
All humans come from Africa,
all of them.
Everybody originated there.
That's the motherland.
So like the only reason why they look different than you is because of natural
selection.
Because the people that live there that you know,
you're obviously,
you need that melon in your skin to protect you from the sun.
That's how people evolved.
And then as soon as people started going to all these colder climates and all
these climates that have a lot of cloud cover,
the people's body started changing and their body started changing to try to
absorb more vitamin D.
That's exactly why people have white skin.
Can they,
can they take hyenas and breed them to be like miniatures?
They could.
Yeah,
for sure.
I saw a guy with a pet,
honey,
you know,
they did it with foxes.
They've done it with foxes and take it foxes in really quickly within 10 years.
Turn them into a completely different thing with a weak jaw and like floppy
ears.
Like to be pets.
Yeah,
well they did.
What they did was they took foxes and when they had a Fox that exhibited any
aggression at all,
the killed it and so then they would breed them again and then any fox that it
showed any aggression at all,
killed it and then they kept doing this and they were doing this to generation
after generation to try to see how many generations it would take to turn a Fox
into like a really docile sort of house pet,
sort of a stupid study.
It's not stupid because it's fascinating to find out how long it takes because
we thought it would take like hundreds of years for an animal to change.
It's essentially it's appearance like its,
its physical appearance is very different than a regular fox changed.
Their coloration changed how their ears,
their ears don't stick up anymore.
They flopped down and show submissiveness.
Same with dogs,
right?
Like all dogs come from wolves.
In the original wolves,
the people kept as pets.
They would just get closer.
They're the ones you get closer to the people by the campfire that people would
feed those wolves and then they would use those wolves.
Still alert them to other animals are coming nearby.
The wolves stayed close to the campfire because the wolves knew that people were
going to give him food.
Then the wolf started protecting those people cause they,
that's where their food source was and the people worked out.
This relationship with wolves.
What country?
This is the human race before there was country,
this is probably,
you know,
we're talking more than 10,000 years ago.
Very recently,
I think it was in Russia.
I think that's where they did this folks doing that.
American Fox was in the 1950s and so they is ruthless study,
but they found out pretty quickly that you can,
you can select,
you can change the way these things look based on which ones you breed with
which ones,
and you've got to think when people migrated out of Africa and they moved across
Asia and move through the Bering strait and into North America,
they may,
they're dealing with brutal cold.
A lot of times they're completely covered up because it's so fucking cold.
Or is that the boxes are more naturally stubborn than dogs.
Oh Cutie face.
They're very playful.
There's a little guys,
even in the wire lock to the pet,
you ever see a grizzly man with the dude made friends with Fox,
like a wild Fox in grizzly man,
like stole his hat and was playing with him.
He's tourism as the that died,
right?
Yeah.
Got fucked up.
I'm fails flying foxes.
What the fuck is up with that flinch girls mean of
flying foxes?
No fines.
There's these weird gigantic Fox looking vulture bat things in Australia that
just a city that just like in the city,
you could just see them in there.
They're senior system kind of bat a bat.
Oh yeah,
they have like a Fox face.
Yeah.
They look like Fox.
Either scary as fuck and they're just like right there and this things are
swimming Australia.
So radical Adam Green tree was sending me videos.
He took these salt,
saltwater crocodiles.
Whoa.
A regular bat.
Australian flying foxes.
It just sometime Fox.
Yes,
flying flats area.
Right.
Is it crazy as that?
Is it actually a flying fox or is that what they call a bat that they call it
that everything looks like it looks like a Fox.
The Fox with winning Shin in soldier and just in Sydney.
Just hanging on the tree thing is sick.
That is insane.
Well,
you know how like we,
we always look good.
Another pterodactyls.
You know how we look at care doctors and we always assume that they have wings
like a bat.
That's what everybody was thought.
But now they're finding out that so many dinosaurs had feathers that it's
entirely possible that Tara doctors were birds.
Did they think the t rex were covered in feathers to write?
Very possible.
There's not a lot of evidence.
There's some evidence that some,
well there's definitely evidence that some dinosaurs had feathers.
They found fossilized dinosaurs with feathers and,
but this is all recently like over the last few decades,
they're starting to find more and more of them like it.
There's,
there's a museum that I went to in Montana and they mocked out a velociraptor
with feathers because look birds like,
like you look at it like an owl.
That's a fucking dinosaur.
Me.
The closest thing to the closest thing to a dinosaur.
They're ruthless,
dude.
Did I tell you about the fucking the wars that I'm having in my backyard?
That's what dude,
there's Fox war.
Not Fox wars.
There's a hawk wars going on in my yard.
They're killing each other.
Birds are killing other birds and they behead them.
So I started going online and reading about it and they eat their head and I'm,
I'm like,
what the fuck eats a hawk's head?
Well,
apparently when birds of prey will kill other birds,
one of the things they do is eat their head.
They eat the headache,
they pull the head of show like dominant.
I don't know man.
I don't know what's going on,
but Jesus Christ.
But one of my neighbors saw um,
a hawk eating a hawk baby like right up the street from me.
And I watched these hawks like swooped down and one of them slammed in my
chicken coop.
Like there's like these juvenile hawks.
And I think one of the things that's going on is I have a fence in my backyard
and it's a,
we just put up a glass fence and these birds just fucking,
we've murked like 15 birds.
Dude.
Did you pick a class fence?
It looks beautiful.
You could see the whole view with these birds.
They don't understand that it's a fence and they swooped down clang and they get
k that fuck,
oh,
just had traveling when she had a video camera.
A little security,
a lot of wasted footage because it only happens like once a month.
It's happened quite a few times where birds have flown down.
We found them just like drunk wandering around the backyard.
Ct just hammered the fuck up.
Blood coming out of their nose like a fag and him with blood coming out of their
nose.
Yeah.
They get kol.
So I think we've killed a bunch of hawks this way.
Hawks have died.
We haven't killed him.
They killed themselves.
Yeah.
Evolution Bitch.
But these other hawks,
these juvenile hawks are now like kind of taken over because of that.
And I think one of the ones that got killed,
one of the hawks that got killed,
look at that fucker.
Look at him.
And he's eaten.
Eaten a bird to decapitated a hawk.
Yeah,
there it is.
He's decapitating a hawk.
Jesus Christ.
They are fucking monster.
Do this.
Ruthless owls are so God damn ruthless.
So cool.
Don't they?
They do look cool.
But it's weird that we've made these things out to be these wise cute creatures
that like give a hoot.
Don't pollute the tootsie roll.
Pop.
Yeah.
The tootsie roll pops.
There's owls everywhere.
The ruthless man there too.
I'd ever seen straight up predators.
Really?
What do you mean?
Every time I see him all the time,
oh look at this bird.
He trying to get away like not today.
Pitch birth the fucking day to Dow.
Ho do you an eat your head.
But um,
so I've found a
decapitated bird in my yard and I posted a picture of it on Instagram and then
started reading up on it.
Apparently it's when birds kill other birds,
they'll do that.
They literally bite their fucking head off like a territory war thing.
Like a gang thing.
I think when these Bert,
my theory,
it's a shitty theory cause I'm not really qualified to have a theory on this,
but I think that these birds slamming into that fence and a few of them dying
have kinda upset the,
the gang situation in my neighborhood,
bird Fuller's,
dude,
owls are so ruthless and they ain't shit compared to eagles.
Eagles of the most ruthless.
Have you ever seen those Harpy Eagles that are they huge shy and they're just
how big huge kills monkeys.
They go after monkeys and they eat a lot of,
um,
what are those little slow things?
Sloths.
Who's talking?
Man.
Harpy Eagles.
That's fucked up because Google Harpy Eagles eat sloths.
I think Thursdays official sloths day.
If you're a slot,
I think Harpy Eagles of the biggest eagles in the world.
I'm pretty sure that thing is Jack.
Oh yeah,
they're ruthless.
Oh,
get this motherfucker swoops down.
What about vultures?
Man,
they're big.
They're big.
The scary cause they're not predators like that.
Sloths are gone or so that's a bummer.
That's a wrap like a sloths man.
But nature just made them like real easy to eat,
but they really don't get fucked with doe because they're not out in the open.
I the,
when they are to get the cat monkey,
she'll goddamn slow.
These these Harpy Eagles,
they eat monkeys like crazy.
He swooped down and Jack monkeys in,
one of the things they found on ancient primate skulls,
they fell out all these weird scratches and all this evidence of predation and
now they think that that,
Ooh.
He's like,
oh,
it's doing,
it's a little left and right now they think that that scratching is probably
some sort of an ancient eagle.
There was preying on ancient hominids Jesus Christ.
Yeah,
birds are real PELICO.
They film this and put this in,
edited this together.
That's not going happen like this.
It's all taken in different years.
But she got her license disbelief just to watch him.
Jack a monkey
do what?
What's the big ass bird that grabs the goats and drops some Feagles.
Those are Golden Eagles.
You're seeing that shit without guns.
What about the small notes?
Such Muslim guys with that falconry?
Yeah.
They use them to hunt.
They hunt rabbits and shit with them at that bird that picks up a straight up
guy,
flies him up and like have fun.
My Man,
I'm pretty sure those are golden eagles.
Yeah.
Golden Eagles hunt goats.
Those are big.
I think those are the biggest eagles in North America.
Those are big ass ego.
That shit.
Worst way to die period.
Where they grab these goats now come with me.
Cool man.
Yeah.
All they're doing is dragging them down.
And the goats sometimes drag the eagles down to the Eagle.
Takes a hit too.
Uhm,
and then the eagles are Ooh,
dinner,
nature fucker videos,
a bad motherfucker.
And then you're kind of out of it.
Then you start to eat and your asshole.
I don't think you're kind of out of it.
And how long did he have to wait for that to happen?
I know with the camera that was caught a perfect,
I know that's a ruthless fucking burst.
Unless they bring their egos.
There's just such drug look chum in the water.
Bill Cosby up those notes.
They get them all hungry and shit.
I got to change the Lens.
The battery's dead.
Oh Man.
Do you ever seen them?
Ones that they use in Mongolia where they chase down wolves?
Oh,
is that it right here?
Yeah.
Oh,
well they do foxes and even wolves,
but they,
uh,
they train these Golden Eagle.
That's how big fucking bird look how big that bird is.
And they put a Gopro on the bird's head.
Holy Shit.
And they sent the bird down.
The bird just put the whacked down on these poor Fox.
They eat.
The was just doing it for the coats.
They kill them.
Oh,
the people,
I don't think they eat them.
They might,
you know,
apparently some trappers in pioneers,
we're big on eating.
Eagles are not eagles.
Um,
uh,
wolves they eat,
they ate a lot of wolves,
like some famous trappers.
Goals were their favorite food,
whatever that lady's Eskimo or whatever.
She is stressed out that this thing is not going to like catch it.
I think that's just what she looks like.
She's living a hard life son.
Look at that.
The look at the fucking Fox trying to fight,
trying to fight back in those clauses.
It's a vice grip.
Oh but you can get that beacon vault soon on that neck.
I think they'd have to put the chase in later.
Like they get like,
like train foxes and have them running and shit.
The bitch hold a whistle.
Is that a thing?
Does that exactly what it is
that Fox put up like decent fight.
The wolf one is even more disturbing.
Oh the Fox is trying,
man.
He's trying,
but he's just kidding.
We got ourselves a fight here.
Yeah.
Well not really cause the Fox can't even bite them.
They're so smart.
They just grab a hold of all birds.
Stress me out man.
Which is weird.
They figured out how to train these things man.
When you call Your Eagle stand against the wind.
Oh that makes sense.
So the ego can hear you.
If you saw one of those things coming right at you,
what?
Strike that overhand knife strength.
I'll just come around at all.
You got to grapple with an eagle.
This fucking the problem.
Have them arms.
I don't think if you hit him there,
they're not heavy enough for it to make like a lot of impact when you hit him.
You know what I'm saying?
It's not like you're hitting a dog.
Right.
If you punch a dog in the face,
a dog weighs 70 pounds.
They're,
they're both squishing the stance you're getting.
You see her coming,
you get hands out,
hands,
handouts,
trips like this.
Hands out like this people coming in,
right?
Yeah.
I'm trying to grab shit and I'm trying to tear it apart.
Trying to rampage Jackson,
trying to get my feet on his dick and I'm trying to pull them legs.
Yes.
Tried to make some Kentucky Fried Chicken drumstick.
Yeah.
You got to pull those legs apart.
Yes.
Slam his fucking head into the ground.
The why you got to land on your arms,
right?
You're like,
yes.
Yeah.
Lands on your arm for them that you getting tore up one arm.
You give them one on one.
Maybe you take your shirt and then wrap that bitch around your arms.
Yeah,
that's it.
and you got to grab them.
Talents.
Got to grab the speed.
I don't think they,
I don't think they attack with a beak as much as they attack with the towns and
eat with the beat.
They come feet first.
Yeah.
Like when they catch a salmon,
how are they going to get around this?
Thinking about how powerful they are.
What if you had to grab a salmon,
what did I say wrong?
You gotta reach in and grab it with your hands.
No chance they swimming down and fly with it.
They snatched it out of the water and fly away with a standard long lasting
males.
Yeah.
You'd probably be able to grab him to,
you'd have to have some serious,
also not very cuddly,
like they're fucking evil
tribal cultures that let their nails grow and they sharpen them and they use
them as like weapons and war.
We have bitch nails are nails fall apart.
You know our nails,
if you get him slammed in the door,
cause we don't use them.
Maybe they're supposed to,
we don't really need caught.
A salmon are supposed to have claws.
That guy's a beast.
The water.
Why this is different,
man.
These things are males are,
he's going to eat it too.
Yeah.
Geez.
Bare hands and eat it raw.
Ooh,
you're not supposed to really eat salmon Sushi even because my Paris like the
shit out of it.
It's not smart.
I feel good.
You can get parasites guys going to eat it raw.
Yeah.
Well a lot of people do,
but when you talk to like people that want to play it safe,
they say you should need anything.
That's a fresh water.
Don't eat fresh water.
Well this guy's,
do you think it's gross?
But do you like Sushi?
You don't need it.
I hate Sushi.
You don't like Sushi Joe Eight he's got,
I used to go to when Eddie and I would go to restaurants,
I used to lose my fucking mind cause ed,
he's like no Cilantro,
onions,
Callidus.
That's how Brian,
I don't need all that chip.
The meat's good.
Why do I need onions and shit on it?
Give me some good meat.
The best is going to Fogo with him though.
Then there's no bro Shit.
You know,
you just get this on this flip that pinch over what's happening with the Fogo de
Chao.
We went in Vegas,
we've chatted up con.
Yeah,
we gained like fucking 10 pounds.
We feast.
It sounds nice.
Oh so good.
I hadn't been there in forever.
We had a good time.
Well you don't really have,
I was going to say munchies,
but when you get the high,
you get high so much.
He probably doesn't fuck with you,
but since you're not got the munchies from pot,
man probably never know.
I mean not get hungry like normal,
but pot was,
it never gave me munchies cause now you're off the hot food tastes way better
though,
that's for sure.
It does.
Yeah.
He's smoking a little bit.
I mean I do too.
Yeah.
Do you use it to write?
No,
you don't,
right?
No.
He should try to.
Right?
Yeah.
Since you're doing stand up,
you should definitely write hi.
Yeah,
I did.
That's the day.
That's where you know what I do don't I do both.
I write sober and I write hi.
I do both and sometimes I break.
Listen to George Carlin talk about that once he was saying that he likes to
write sober and then he touches everything,
not punches it up when he's high.
Well,
that makes sense.
Yeah.
Like smoke a little weed and then go over the material back.
But what's funny about it?
Yeah.
I like both men.
I like writing,
writing sober and riding high,
but when I write high it's like,
are you just get these gifts?
It's like the universe gives you these gifts.
Like where is this?
Even comedies as it funny too.
When you're highly,
you look back over when you're sober,
that guy,
what the fuck was definitely that?
I used to have a bit about it,
but I literally wrote down a Unicorn as a donkey from the future and then I went
down and looked at my notes and,
well,
what the fuck does that even mean?
Exactly.
The
funny thing about it that you didn't write down exactly and you forgot it was so
high,
but I wrote it down and then I went over it two days after the fact.
It was like,
what the fuck is wrong with me?
I wrote that down,
I bring a bunch of shit down.
Like I have to see every now and then cause a lot of what I write down,
if I'm high I'll write down some shit like at the comedy store or something like
that.
And then I have to go over my notes when I'm sober.
I'm like,
Eh,
I do not.
I do on your phone and do it physically.
Well physically like with a computer and then I write notes on the computer.
What does that mean?
I mean it's a tiny the computer like physically,
right?
Like uh,
I thought physically was like with a pen.
No,
but this is what I would probably wrong way to say it,
but I have three stages,
right?
I write with a computer,
but then I write things down on paper.
Like if I have to like do a set,
I write a set list out with paper.
I'm really interested in this new Samsung man.
The Samsung note eight.
Yeah,
because the note eight,
you write on the lock screen,
you don't even have to open up an application.
I like that.
Right on the lock screen.
And you write it with a pen.
You could write like a hundred pages of notes just on the lock screen and you
could save him.
Have you seen that yet?
What does an apple do?
That shit.
They'll jump on.
Samsung's got it,
man.
You apple gets sued left and right for patents.
They got sued for these new,
uh,
animated emojis that are coming out with,
on the iPhone x 10 whatever it is.
My phone.
So fucking rough right now.
I need one which got seven plus but gets bro.
It's horrible.
It's all my wife got the eight.
It's the shit.
Is it nice?
It looks just like this,
but the camera's way better.
The camera's wicked and you can get it right now.
But the thing about the new one,
the uh,
the x,
the axe is weird man because a,
it doesn't have a fingerprint thing where you open it,
you open it with your Mug,
with your face.
Stare at it.
I don't like the open,
so I'm like,
get your phone and just do this.
Hey,
what's up man?
I'm like your face and go get,
you can go get the eight right now.
The eight yes.
You get the eight right now.
I need to get that bitch tomorrow.
Eight is basically this phone but way better.
It's exact same.
This is a seven but the aid is the exact same phone.
It has like all the stain but I'll tell you what man,
my phone has been fucking up lately.
The old one right to apple does on purpose.
Don't get that new one.
They says you need an update update cause they play those games.
They dropped that bug.
Fuck.
As soon as you update then you're fucked.
I held it off for a while.
I'm going super,
super strong.
My phone,
not only is it freeze but now when I like say if you sent me a text like today
it happened.
You sent me a text saying which door should I go into and I replied to you and
then I went to look at my phone and there was no place to reply.
It didn't exist.
I couldn't pull it up so I should I,
I went,
I hit the home button and then I reopened the text messages back to the same
thing,
so I had to physically like swipe up and close out the text message program and
then start it up again just to get a dialogue where I could like press the keys
in.
It wouldn't let me press the keys.
It's apple.
Tony,
get a new phone.
You need your cell phone.
The iPhone eight and I think,
I think I'm at the six still.
I don't even know what this a dam.
That's the three c Jamie,
Jamie,
see if you could pull up a video on the Samsung Galaxy note eight.
This galaxy note eight has got me very,
I'm very curious,
but there's a bunch of things that apple does that keeps you on the tit.
One of them is that airdrop,
like if made it forever,
then once I went to it,
so easy man.
It's pretty easy.
So easy.
Yeah,
everything's pretty good use that.
I use it all the time,
but say like if we made a video right here,
I would airdrop it to you.
She can't text it because the file is so big.
If you instead of it texting it just goes through Bluetooth because you're near
me and it sends it to you in full.
So this is it right here.
This is the galaxy note eight.
It's fucking huge and it's all screen.
They have a little bit of room for like the speakers on it but the screen is
gigantic.
I like that.
And they pulled that pen out.
That Penn is so dope dude.
It lets you do all kinds of shit.
Like if someone sends you a picture,
you could highlight things with that pen.
Dude,
you're selling the fuck out of me right now.
Look at them market.
You could write notes with your hand.
See this to me is big because then I don't have to take a notebook with me.
I don't need a light pad or anything like that.
You write it like look at this.
This guy wants to highlight some shit.
Look,
you could translate things I guess to another country like do that and boom,
it translates shit for you.
It charges wirelessly.
Yeah,
look at it.
I'm a spokesman from Biloxi.
Look at that.
Ooh,
but Joe,
how's it work?
If I went from the apple phone that does all my shit transfer over.
No.
Yeah,
sort of the problem is the real pro.
I tried it with a Google pips pixel just for shits and giggles.
The real,
we'll get that like he's white and notes with that thing.
Come on.
So on,
on the lock screen,
the real problem is,
uh,
I messages.
So like say if someone's like used to sending you ims does,
you send them my messages.
It doesn't want to send you a text.
It wants,
it wants to continue to send imessages and it takes a long time to switch over.
I actually called up apple and I said,
I want you to remove me from the I message database.
Like remove my email from ims,
iMessage,
remove me.
And they said,
why?
I said,
because I've got a Google phone.
why did you do that?
And I said,
that's none of your business pitch removing me motherfucker.
So they removed
me from the a I message database and it still wouldn't work.
I mean it would work half the time.
It's a deal breaker for me.
All the people that had android phones all work great.
Like,
yeah,
but how many people have android phones?
I know a few people that have android phones.
Yeah,
he ain't,
Edwards has one.
Steve,
uh,
Rinella has one.
I have a few friends that have androids.
Ramey.
Warren has one but the majority don't.
So you have ice shoes.
Yeah.
And you don't get it.
You get,
I get sad when I see a green text.
I like bling to,
it bums me out like fuck,
he's got one of them.
I judged people.
People do judge me,
but somebody,
some comedian had a bit about it.
I think what's cool can up with a girl and you know,
she's broke when you get a green text from her broke screen,
like people,
someone Ah,
dude,
your phone bumps and me out of friends.
Seg is all your phone bums me out,
man,
because it's broken.
It's all screens.
All broke my case.
You live in your life.
Yeah,
you're right.
What's cool about the green tags is the person you're texting with doesn't see
that.
You're like,
you know,
you're texting and then sometimes the bubble,
sometimes you're not writing anything.
You're just reviewing the tax,
your conversation,
trying to figure out high and they think that you're writing something and then
they,
then you see the dirt riding seven,
then they stop.
You know,
I'm not sure
that I did.
I've done that to my wife where I'm about to text something.
I don't,
then I don't,
and then she'll say,
why were you thinking about something?
And then you,
your mind
about something.
You were about to write some shit and then it turned off.
What were you thinking?
Tell me.
Kissy Emoji.
But I decided it's not appropriate for the,
I took off the thing where it says read.
Oh yeah,
I was just gonna say that that's,
that's a bad,
you might not have,
you might have that on there.
When you get a text message,
if you look at it and you send the thing,
like if you look at it,
that person knows you looked at it.
Yeah.
If you're looking for,
did I say
it's like if someone texts me,
I might just go straight to the texts,
you know,
just to see like what the messages because I don't have time.
Right.
You know,
we don't have time for everybody,
so fucked up.
The other day I got 39 text messages.
I counted up from a psycho or a bunch of people in the day,
39 I can't keep up with all the time.
39 different people.
Text messaged me,
what is my job?
Just replying texts that took us up.
That's my job.
Then I got to sit down and just,
and then people go,
Hey,
what's up?
Like those,
those don't get a reply.
Hey,
what's up?
What's up?
Call me or my family or our aunt or,
or answer a non question.
Maybe I'll get back to that.
Like for me it's like right now I got to answer these and I'll try to catch up
to those.
You go to one,
you lock yourself away doing a podcast for three hours,
you're going to have a million messages.
You don't have time to,
you got to get in your car.
This is one of the few times that I guarantee that I'm not going to communicate
with anybody any other way.
So one of the few times like doing a podcast,
this,
one of the cool things about these kinds of conversations,
like this is the only way we have these conversations.
Like even if we eat dinner,
we don't have these kind of conversations.
You acted as distracted,
you checking your phone,
got to take.
This is a lot of shit going on.
Like the art of conversation is lost a lot of people.
And one of the ways we practice it is by doing these podcasts.
Yeah.
This is like a real hangout on your phones are off.
Yes.
Have you had anyone come in and try to keep on,
stay on their phone?
Yes.
Get the fuck.
Russell Peters cannot leave his phone alone.
I can't be on the show that he cannot leave his phone alone.
Those like,
yeah.
Yeah.
So,
uh,
I was gonna hold on.
I go Russel,
go Russel.
Everybody's here.
We're right here.
The million people are listening a bit.
It is,
you know what?
It's a bummer.
Everyone's got,
everyone's got a phone and everyone's got a lot of work to do on the God damn
phone.
It's nice to be able to hang out with somebody and you're like,
let's just get on our phones together and we'll talk every now and then and I'll
show you a video and we're cool and we're not offending anybody.
Everyone's just on your phone.
There's nothing wrong with that.
Nothing wrong with that.
And then,
you know what I mean?
It's like we got,
I want to hang out with you,
but I got to do business and we could talk when there's something to talk about
for sure.
I got to handle some shit for sure.
Don't you notice from doing a lot of podcasts,
I would like if you have conversations with some people,
some people that are just not really listening to you,
not in podcasts,
but in the real world,
like you get good at this.
Like you,
you do podcasts a lot,
so you're really good at having conversations.
But when you go out in the real world and have conversations with people,
there's motherfuckers are just aren't listening.
They're just talking the tracking at you.
They're not even responding to what you're saying.
There's thinking about what they want to get done and their agenda.
They're in a different,
in a text,
they're like texting someone else and in some serious business and they're like,
no,
no.
I mean when you're having a conversation with someone and they're not even like
tuned in to what you're saying.
Like there's a lot of people that are just bad at talking.
Yeah.
That communicators and those people are bad at podcast.
Every now and then I'll get one of those people on a podcast and you're like,
are you even here with me?
You will listen to me like it's work.
Yeah,
it's work.
Cause you're constant trying to come up constantly and you trying to like bring
them in.
So we're trying to get them to hook on.
Exactly.
Trying to get them to go to the store,
connect with me.
Please come there.
Come back.
Oh,
that a bummer.
To lose.
The audience feels it cause they're like,
oh,
this guy sucks dude.
Yeah.
I've,
I've talked to people after I had someone on,
they go,
hey that guy something was off,
right?
Yeah.
It was a little off.
It wasn't,
he's like,
he seemed like he was on some drugs or something.
Like that's another thing I'm finding it's how many fucking people are on speed.
So
Adderall,
Adderall.
Well that's not technically 100% crystal meth until Pharaoh is meth.
It really is.
Like does the same thing.
No,
it does the same thing,
but when you're on Adderall you're like,
you've got a prescription.
You don't feel like you're,
you don't feel like you're a meth head.
There's a difference between,
you know what I mean?
Oh yeah.
This difference between the,
that are all still have their teeth for a,
not all of them
before we started the show,
this is the same guy.
Tommy caffeine is bad for you.
You told me caffeine,
same thing.
His coat.
Well,
caffeine is a cousin of coke.
While they're in the same caffeine.
They're in the same,
unless,
I mean this was mainstream information,
so maybe it a stimulant,
but it's real.
It's like,
cause they used to put coke and Coke a cola,
right?
Then they go,
well they still use coca leaves to make the flavor of,
do you know that cocaine,
like the number one provider of medical cocaine is Coca Cola.
Do you know how this works?
Coca Cola [inaudible] coca leaves,
they have like cocoa leaves that you would get cocaine from.
That's the flavor.
It's secret to the flavor of Coca Cola.
Shit's delicious flavor soda.
It's just better than tap coca cola.
Forget.
It's just better than Pepsi in the can forget that.
It's just a matter [inaudible] I love it.
He hit the Mexican sugar.
I love that shit.
But the way they make it is with cocoa leaves,
they extract the cocaine from the cocoa leaves and the company that extracts the
cocaine from those cocoa leaves.
They sell it to like they use it as medical cocaine Escobar enterprises.
It's fucking crazy,
man.
It's crazy.
Let's say medical cocaine,
medical cocaine.
Damn.
When are they going to legalize that?
Well,
medicare,
they use for surgeries and shit.
Why do medical cocaine?
You can ignore things down numbs things like,
like locally without like,
you know,
instead of like Novacane Novacane by the way,
related to cocaine,
Lidocaine,
Lidocaine.
I had that shit when I had my nose fixed.
They put the Lidacain in.
How many doctors are taking this medical cocaine and and,
and doing crazy things with it.
Do you remember Joel Wallach?
Dead doctors don't lie.
You turned me onto that.
You turned me on to that.
But it was a coke head.
No,
he was a doctor who was into minerals.
He's talking to you about how,
it's weird that people who are veterinarians know that if you have livestock,
you have to supplement the minerals and the livestock.
But people don't think about mineral deficiencies in food.
When you talk about people that have a regular diet,
especially when they don't have a vegetable rich diet there with,
with animals,
with livestock,
you don't have a health insurance.
So you got to,
they know.
Farmers know.
Yeah,
give him these minerals.
Otherwise your livestock's going to be shit.
So there's no,
but when it comes to humans,
we don't look at it the same way,
but you know a lot of people do.
They understand the importance of more minerals.
Now with Joel Wallach,
one of the things he was talking about and is how we put all our faith in
doctors when it comes to like health,
but how little education doctors actually have a nutrition and then how many
doctors are doing drugs?
How many doctors are like tons?
I know free pills.
What are they doing?
Access to all that.
You don't think shit.
You know what?
What are they doing?
What's going on?
The ones that you've heard of,
the ledger ones that I've heard of them hung out with.
I mean they,
they party hard.
Men that have access to a lot of stuff.
They make a lot of money.
You know the party hard.
The people cope.
Smart Coke goddamn cocaine
are totally dope.
Dope,
dope,
dope dope.
What does that Adderall and Fed Amin,
amphetamine aspartate.
Yeah,
it's functional.
You're saying you've had people,
you were saying people that come on hundred percent on it had a bunch of people
that I've asked just flat out ask because they're just going,
yeah,
they take their,
so they talk so fast and there's so much going on.
Like there's no way this guy's an on speed.
And then it will come out later in the conversation that they're on Adderall,
that they take Adderall,
they have prescription.
They always like,
well,
I have add.
Oh,
is that add I've got add to motherfucker.
I can go get a prescription.
Yeah.
I mean,
what does it,
have you ever taken Adderall?
No,
I took it and didn't shut the fuck up,
but I couldn't focus on anything.
I took it in college,
write a paper and sewing.
Come in by k.
How's the pizza?
Had gone a fucking rant about pizza.
We got nothing done.
Nothing done.
That's like speed.
Speed is supposed to be good for organizing.
You know,
growing up I was
in Sweden,
uh,
you lose your teeth.
Well,
it's not just that,
I think your heart,
it's just like overworked.
Too many beats.
I think it freaks you out.
Fast pounding or uneven heartbeats.
Pain or burning when you urinate,
that's banging.
Chicks that are on speed,
uh,
taken more than usual.
Feelings of extreme happiness or sadness,
tremors,
hallucinations,
unusual behavior or motor tics.
Big,
dangerously high blood,
high blood.
What not terrible.
Let's be real.
Not Awful.
Well see there is a lot of people that are on this stuff on a daily basis.
Dangerously high blood pressure,
severe headache,
buzzing in your ears,
anxiety.
There's a lot of people that are on this a lot like theirs.
Okay.
And the entertainment.
Let's take it,
not just entertainment.
Journalism.
Journalism is a big one.
This guy who was in here,
who's a professor actually told me that he knows so many fucking journalist and
then I started asking journalists and they confirmed it with me.
Like,
yeah,
everybody's on it.
And I go,
everybody who was,
everybody I know that's a successful journalist has taken Adderall.
I go,
why?
He goes,
he's got deadlines.
You can work.
You don't get tired,
you get things done,
you focus.
He goes,
you got like laser beam focus.
And I go,
how many of them were abusing it?
And he goes,
they're all abusing it.
Damn.
It's like steroids for writing Gat.
Right.
PD for writing.
So let me ask you this.
If you had to guess,
what's the number of prescriptions every year for Adderall in the United States?
Let's guess we'll say that again.
The number of prescriptions every year for Adderall in the United States has to
know me to say 5 million.
I'm going with 30 million.
30 I was going to 20 to 30 million.
Yeah.
How many right now,
how many people are on Adderall?
See they don't do it that way.
They,
they write prescriptions written.
So like say if you see three months worth,
you might use it four times in a year.
So you would be for,
right.
So let's find out.
I'm saying 30 I'm going to go,
I'm going to go 2020 let's say a little lower.
Five when no one,
when I said you still gonna go with five.
Five Eddie,
come on turn 10 which peer pressure,
Bro,
don't give him.
Stick with five.
What'd we got best?
I could find is from 2012 and it says roughly 16 million aderol prescriptions
are written for adults between 20 and 39 well that's not good for 2012 five
years ago.
It doesn't include kids.
A lot of kids took it in school and then in the college and are now those
probably reporters today it's about 25 years ago.
Those kids are 20 now,
right?
It could be 15 now they're 20 yeah,
well they were,
yeah.
This is only started with age 20 or so.
Kids that were in high school were 16 1718 up to statistics.
I just tried to type in 2016 and this is an article from 2016 use in these
stats.
So interesting.
Very interesting.
It's just,
it's crazy cause it is speed.
You can get it prescribed to you.
All you have to do is say,
oh just can't focus tired all the time and just don't know what to do.
Okay.
They just write your speed when it help you in writing to really everything.
Maybe some people say it doesn't help you creatively because you're so like
that.
It's better for like organizing things,
moving out loads together,
painting your house like the late great.
Robert Schimmel.
Do you know Robert Sherman was standup comedian?
Hilarious dear friend.
Great Guy,
died a few years back.
He acts densely,
took Adderall.
He uh,
was he thought it was,
he had it actually had a heart attack and um,
he went to try to thought he was taking his heart medication.
He took the wrong shit and it took someone else's Adderall because doctor and
he's like,
ah,
what do I do?
He goes,
how much did you take?
And it looks at the bottle,
tells him the dosage.
He goes,
going to be fine.
you just,
you're just going to be up for a while and you're going to be very speedy.
And so he just said,
I just organize my notes.
He said,
I just got in front of my computer and I couldn't stop organizing,
just going over my notes and just pulling out pages after pages and writing
things down.
He says,
he said,
I've never been more focused in my life.
Here's what,
I'm scared to try it again.
I wonder what it's like working out on it.
A lot of people working out on it.
We had a lady in here recently who said she works out on it since she gets
pumped,
right,
goes nuts.
When I was nine,
when I was 19 that was this 23 year old heavy metal Chicco had some speed and
she was hot at the time and uh,
we did a little bit and my Dick was so god damn small and she was,
she was determined to blow it up.
I kept saying,
I'm sorry,
it won't work.
It doesn't work.
It doesn't work because of speaking.
She goes,
don't worry.
I got all day.
And she was,
she just went on forever and she did eventually resurrected.
God blesses was wicked.
That's the fucking speed.
Made her suck on nick all day long.
She going to give up.
No.
Imagine how long it would take.
I imagine when you do,
I can only imagine you had big does not work.
It just,
just,
sure.
Yeah.
Whoa.
I was not good man.
I don't fuck this terrible.
I don't recommend it to anybody.
It was terrible.
I was young,
I was 19,
she was hot.
A lot of pool players used to take speed.
They said it helped their game.
I did take a bunch of different kinds of speed to focus on the ball Jan make
there cause you know,
pools a very like,
it's a lot of intense focus and like tiny adjustments you're making and you got
to really like really concentrate on the angles and what you're trying to
accomplish.
It's a very mentally taxing game and you're gambling.
So a lot of these guys,
they gamble for like 10,
12 hours sessions.
Here's a question for your golden snitch friend.
If I have a prescription for Adderall,
can I fight in UFC one up if I've crazy upset.
Tracy crazy.
Tim Crater,
uh,
actually got pulled from a card because he had a real deficit and he was on
Adderall.
They pull them from a car to way back in the day.
This was like ultimate fighter days when he was off the,
when,
when it was the wild west.
Yeah,
exactly.
Adderall.
The new drug of choice of many major leaguers.
Wow.
Meaning baseball though.
Now one,
look,
this is,
this is football.
You're saying
the,
okay,
baseball I've always heard they fuck with that are all non star,
all his legal and easily obtainable but also dangerous if abuse use in major
league has reached absurd level baseball employee.
Sir.
Dangerous have used but yeah,
but the thing is like also if you use it,
you might be the best fucking baseball player alive and make a kajillion
dollars.
It does provide you with energy that you would normally have.
It's cheating.
Says Dr. Richard Lustberg,
New York state licensed psychologist and member of the American psychological
association.
Yeah,
baseball.
I tried to make money but yeah,
it's weird cause the 15 years to make money in baseball,
I'm taking,
I'm injecting Adderall into my veins if I'm shooting it right into my Dick
[inaudible] correct one.
You try and get paid,
but in fighting,
if you,
if you legit have a problem,
yeah,
but what is that problem?
See that's the problem that to that it's never been clearly defined to me.
I've talked to a bunch of psychologists and psychiatrist about it.
I'm like,
what is Adhd?
Mike,
how do you define it?
And he defined it by a series of characteristics that people have.
But you could just say you have those.
I mean,
you could,
you could complain about all sorts of things that are on the list.
It's not like they test you like,
oh,
you have syphilis.
Hey Man,
let me test you.
Oh Yeah Bro,
you got a disease.
It's not like you guys are all in me.
But even when I was a kid,
like if,
if you were distracted and couldn't sit still,
you just think like,
he has a lot of energies needs to play or go outside more like no one was
fucking taking it,
you know,
medication,
UFC,
exact frank mir was not the denied an Adderall.
Um,
there are pubic use exemption by Nevada Athletic Commission.
So what did he say?
He was so he got one.
So he got one interesting Adderall.
He was granted one by you Sada.
That's interesting because maybe
Tim crater could have been granted it,
but it was public.
I'm not saying anything that people don't know about.
They're all talking about it at the time.
Um,
you know what,
I think that free for the people who really need it.
This has got to be very frustrating to see people like use it and abuse it
because Brian Callahan,
I was like,
you,
you have add like I've never seen before.
Oh but he's all over the place and he was like,
oh for sure I have add and went to Dr. He's like,
Nah,
you're good.
Rolling.
Yeah.
Dot.
I told him to fire his doctorate wines.
Not On Adderall?
No he's on,
he played at Ross on life.
Fitzsimmons is on it.
Brian didn't want,
he was on um,
he's actually,
he's on Ritalin for Tim is on Ritalin.
What's the difference?
I don't know.
Speed.
It's speed.
He does a podcast the other day and his knee was like,
he does like does a lot of like movement.
It's like constantly moving a lot.
And someone asked him on Twitter like what's that about?
And he's like Ritalin where he just wanted to talk to Beth and first pot.
No,
no,
no.
He's been on it cause he is legitimately,
he has legitimate add,
which whatever the fuck that was going to say,
we don't know what led them to add means.
Okay,
let's
excuse me.
Let's define it.
Like let's try to see if someone has a definition.
What is legitimate?
What do you think it is?
What do you guys think of this?
I think it's so who can't focus on fucking anything and they're distracted by
everything.
Well it's also like,
yeah,
there's definitely that.
It's also patterns and the patterns of behavior that you develop in your life.
But this also probably people that have a legitimate disease.
They were sitting legitimately something wrong with their brain.
The question is how many people legitimately have something wrong versus how
many people are just abusing it cause he's just assholes.
They just want to you speed,
get,
get all that energy and get fired up.
Is it possible,
is there any chance maybe in some cases add or some kind of brain dysfunction is
caused by the vaccines?
Maybe?
Is there a possibility that it's a vaccine?
No dairy?
No.
I don't know.
There's definitely side effects.
Almost every medication that you take for certain people.
Adult attention deficit hyperactivity disorder.
Adhd is a mental health disorder that includes a combination of persistent
problems such as difficulty paying attention,
Brian Cowen,
hyper activity,
Brian Count and also behavior.
Brian Kaolin,
Ada county,
too.
Unstable relationships,
growing count,
poor work or school performance.
Brian,
Callan and low self esteem brow.
The doctor went,
Nah,
you don't have low self esteem.
Can't give it to you bro.
And other problems.
What are the other problems?
We don't even want to talk about those when other problems be specific.
Motherfucker,
this is a,
this is a medical diagnosis,
but if you read that,
that's basically every kid you've ever met.
Well,
here's the problem.
You get kids,
kids are filled with energy and they want to play and they want to have fun.
Then when you want to be stimulated and then you make them sit in your shit,
talk you,
they sit in an uncomfortable bullshit,
plastic chair.
Listen,
some monotone asshole who's teaching them nonsense going wrong.
Not,
it's not the kids issue part of it,
but parents want to give it to their kids because they just want the kids to pay
attention.
You know,
I had a neighbor who got their kid on Ritalin and there was nothing wrong with
this kid and he got the kid on Ritalin and was just like this,
all the stupid pants.
He's just like,
fuck,
focus the spot.
Hey,
focus focuses father.
He just listened by killing video games too.
Probably get them in front of Matt and Hell Yeah.
Can just kind of plays on bitches.
Yeah.
Probably had a lot of friends though.
It's,
it's definitely dangerous how many people are medicated,
but the real question is like how many people actually could use the medication
versus how many people are medicated because doctors are like to meet someone
really w who has that problem,
who really has add and figure it out.
I bet some of them kids were seriously abused as kids and they just come out
just in,
they're all just fucked,
fucked up.
That's definitely a possibility.
Not of abuse going on.
Well,
there's also like emotional abuse.
People just yell at their kids,
beat their kids.
There's kids that people get ignored.
Kids don't have friends who grow up with parents that are just assholes and
they're just,
they saw life is like,
they're constantly walking on eggshells.
They're all fucked up psychologically because of its bomber man.
Yeah,
it's a bummer dude.
You here,
I can't read horrible stories but I've read some story about some guy in Texas
that he's,
his three year old daughter wouldn't drink her milk.
So he made her stand outside by the tree and she disappeared brother.
He went back out 15 minutes and she was gone and the police went looking for,
they can't find her.
She disappears.
You hear in the interview what he said.
What'd he say?
I put her out there and they do think happening.
There's,
there's been a lot of siding of coyotes in the,
in the area and they're like,
what the fuck is wrong with you coyotes?
I read that.
I read that exact dark like couldn't sleep that night man.
I could not stop thinking about that has to do with kids.
It fucks me three year old outside cause she wouldn't finish her mouth and she
has a disability.
She has a disability.
She went finished your milky like fucking moron who they've already taken the
other one in the morning when it finished her mouth.
So this morning puts out a tree at two in the morning and then Dave or child
custody or he came,
took the one of the kids way before.
It's
almost like definitely that kid getting violent guy with that guy.
I would fuck up for free.
Yeah,
that guy does that guy.
That guy should be toward the fact that he could do that to a baby,
a three and his own man,
his own daughter.
And I think about that.
I think of Mike and I think y'all scared he'd be by the tree.
It fucks up the world missing Todd.
She's still missing,
right?
There's no update on that.
No,
they never found her.
She probably got eight and they got deserves the coyotes.
Jesus Christ.
Meanwhile,
I probably killed her.
I need you that he made that story up and you might be right.
You might be right at,
he might be right.
Might have like,
I deserved the death bell.
And there's the proof that a story that sounds like a,
I called him something.
Did it either way.
If he just left her outside,
if he knew this coyotes around,
he's asking his kid to get anything back.
He might've wanted the kid to get eaten by a code because he's a bad person.
He's a piece of shit and he's,
you know,
raising a kid tests you.
It's like,
you know,
there's some people that are just fucked in the head.
Damn.
We should end on this and definitely shouldn't it.
What else you guys get?
What's not in on that bullshit?
Sad.
I know.
Too much sadness,
ma'am.
There's a lot of sadness.
My man.
Lots of good shit too.
Yeah,
there's a lot of great shit in the world,
but content,
there's a lot of fucking more so that'll fuck your day and you can't,
the thing is you can't fix them like a guy like that.
Like the once a guide does that to his daughter,
what do you,
you know,
you're not fixing that car.
That guy's dead.
Think about that guy.
His friends too.
And if you'd like,
how was your night last night?
Oh my fucking kid.
One finches bottle.
So I left her outside.
What the fuck do you hang out with?
Who else are you hanging out with?
We can talk like that and everyone thinks it's all good.
You know the thing is like you can't forgive someone for that and you have to
kill them.
What?
How do you forgive someone for doing that to a baby?
Like if someone beats a baby to death,
you don't,
there's no returning from that.
Get a torture.
But then people go,
it's a mental illness.
Publicly torture him publicly.
But does that,
is that really good?
Is that fix anything?
Does it like,
Yep.
It'll scare people.
There's the bigger picture and people go,
it listened to mental illness issue,
so we need to fix them.
And it's like,
yeah,
the mental illness issue is a weird one because I saw something about huffpost
had some thing about pedophiles and they eventually took it down I think,
but this guy was saying,
I'm not a monster,
I'm a pedophile.
And he's basically saying that he has these thoughts.
He just doesn't act on them.
And everybody was like,
what?
Holy Fuck.
What the fuck are you?
What did they say that for?
Everything,
right.
For if you,
if you rape kids,
if you're a child molester,
if you're uh,
uh,
you know,
if you shoot people,
it's a mental illness.
That molesters are running this planet,
that those are the one that you opened the door fucked up.
Those are the real key here.
The Donald Trump's gonna open up the JFK dump.
How about that?
All the dump of documents from the JFK that had been sealed up by all the other
presidents like the JFK assassination investigation,
they sealed some documents up because they're too sensitive and like whatever
those documents,
they shred those documents.
How can now,
why would damning documents B exists?
These are people from 1962 also Trump for sure folks on something else and this,
hey,
this is not a bad thing to focus on.
If he show me are the things we know for sure,
but first of all,
no one really can be president.
Let's be honest,
there's not a single person that could focus on the economy and healthcare and
international relations and the environment and like there's no way to do with
the word job though.
Yes,
yeah,
for sure.
But there's not enough time in the world the focus on any of those.
The Sony should focus on Donald Trump should focus on the Vegas shooting that he
hasn't said Shit about it.
That's how we're ending it.
You know what I mean?
Well,
what do you think?
There was some shady shit going on,
but here's the thing about this,
this Kennedy assassination,
one of the reasons why if I was him,
I would focus on the Kennedy assassination as they might fucking kill him.
Like it's entirely possible that he's thinking that he could get assassinated
hundred percent of herself.
That's why he's opening it would if I wouldn't think there was any files,
like why would they,
are those files exist?
They should have been burned a long time ago.
Yeah,
you would think so.
There's no files and also is it,
it doesn't have the highest security of all time.
Like they,
they pay the most to protect amount of all time because there's such a threat
now.
Oh,
he has crazy security doors on his limo.
They had a video of him.
I was a,
God,
I can't stop coughing in there.
I was going,
I was looking at this image of,
uh,
him.
Uh,
there was a video of him getting out of the limo and I was like,
look at that door on that fucking limo.
And then I went to some images of the limo.
The Limo door is like that thick.
Is it different than Obama's though?
That the standard one I Cadillac makes.
I never looked at the other one,
but I mean the,
the,
the doors are fucking ridiculous.
Bombproof yeah,
they're sick.
That would be the dopest car to drive around.
And you'd be like,
fuck this fire away.
Burroughs me around that.
You being there sipping tea.
We'll add these up whole world.
Kiki.
Yeah.
They make a car that you can buy.
There's a company called Dev Rolo,
D v R O l o.
And they make a car like your truck,
a Toyota Tundra.
But they make that motherfucker bulletproof.
I used to work for a company that used to bulletproof vehicles for two weeks.
It was a fiber.
Glad they do at fiberglass.
I couldn't hang.
Yes,
I quit.
It was too hard.
Oh,
the fiberglass fumes.
We were Shitty Gig.
We made cars for diplomats and for like a mobile check cashing vans out.
Those are the big bangs.
Mobile Sense.
And then private cars.
We just,
you just fill the doors up with fiberglass.
Just sheets of fiberglass.
Yeah,
that's it.
But what about the windows?
Um,
I dunno.
I don't remember how the windows are thick as fuck.
And I don't think the windows windows are different.
Fact down this bulletproof be bulletproof underneath,
make it bomb proof from underneath fiberglass,
the shit out of the doors.
But this Dev Rolo Company,
they do like consumer cars.
And,
uh,
I don't know what they do at the window.
Brazil.
They're popular.
Bulletproof cars like shirts.
Hell yes to Mexicans update new Cadillac.
Presidential limousine to debut later in 2017 Cadillac just runs that shit.
Got your acids Cadillac called the beast America.
Oh,
what a fucking clever name.
Beast.
I think.
Hey that can't be cheap.
Wait a minute.
They're selling it to anybody.
How come I can't buy what the president has?
Come on Bro.
What do you think?
How much one of those limos goes for?
What's the money?
I'm gonna say 600,000 oh no,
no.
If the taxpayers are paying for,
that's Tourbillion.
It's that tax money shit.
No bid contract.
A billion dollar limousine.
Two plus three plus two.
Layout means it can carry chief executive and a couple of aides on most
journeys.
Pasture compartment was still offer conference style seating for five and the
real rear passenger doors will still be positioned to the front of the rear
quarter windows.
They will partially obscure the two rear seats.
If I was president,
I want to have a catholic like something like that.
But the front end and be a viper out the American out of the Punisher War van
put say fucking white skull on the side of it too.
Could do like a big ass long Bronco.
Just something so fucking American Bronco.
It'd be sick.
Maybe a Ram.
Dodge Ram.
Yeah.
Bulletproof a smart car.
Be a bomber man.
Those things are so ridiculous.
How many of those do you see a lot of?
You see a little of them in Hollywood.
I feel like they're dying out.
You think so?
Yeah.
People don't want to save gas that much.
Again,
get laid.
There are so lame.
There's so many.
It's like a motorcycle.
You're dead.
Yeah,
but girl riding a Prius with you.
Like how he's just really glean Ygrene Vegan Shit.
He's really into the environment.
Who is that chat?
Osho Cinco has a hooked up smart car.
Yeah.
What is he doing these days?
That's a big smart car.
Right at the special one.
He was rumored or they tried to do a flag football league him in too.
And a couple of other players.
They used to be an NFL and they did like a pilot game I think to try to see if
anybody was interested.
But he said he's managed to stay fairly relevant.
He's really big on Twitter.
He plays a,
he goes around the war,
wound up a world but the United States and challenges people in FIFA,
he says we'll play them at their game.
And He's good.
He's good at physicals.
I mean like real soccer.
Keep his name out there.
But flag football sir.
Absolutely not the same as that.
Three on three basketball league.
He's got a fucking smart car.
I've never seen a hooked up smart card.
I don't want to see a map.
Slack vented roaders no,
you're not into it.
You're angry.
It's just not for me man.
He look a little angry.
Just not for me.
Yeah,
it looks like it's taken a fence.
Yeah.
Those are not the best cars to drive around and seem super dangerous.
Prius got cool cause Leonardo Dicaprio,
you know Bronx,
him,
you know,
he doesn't really rock them.
He just rocked him where the photo shoot and he hopped out of that and right
into his Ferrari.
Mumble a bit
while I was getting blown snorting Adderall.
Brian still have the Tesla now.
Oh he had,
he does have the feds,
a son and he does have the Tesla.
It's all fucking,
you know Brian,
he doesn't kick out to have a Tesla.
It's just not as well.
That car man.
Is that the test?
The Fisker fits the fish.
They caught on fire though,
didn't they?
Well they did.
The old ones did when they had that,
a hurricane that hit the east coast couple of years back,
they had all these bitches parked near some water and the tide came in and they
all blew up
when they went under water.
They just started exploding.
Can get for cheap.
If it rains,
you're kind of fucked.
But they're cool.
Well I think they've fixed that.
Not they're out of business now.
Their back.
Are they bad?
Fiskars damn,
I want one.
They have a new car.
There's all the cars.
Look at them all.
They're all just fucking just cinders.
They've all just blew up and caught on fire.
That is fucking hilarious,
man.
Look at them all.
Fuck
manage the people that own them like,
hey,
you fucking piece of shit.
What if I drive through a puddle?
Damn.
That car's gonna blow up.
That's a sweet ride though.
That's like a,
you know,
that's nothing for chairs.
Those are the fee.
It's way cool.
That's Linaro not Justin Bieber beeps.
Chrome one,
the chrome one.
I think that's the future is electric cars.
It's just they're not quite ready for prime time.
Right.
I just can't get it.
I know for the environment I get it.
I liked that aspect.
I just can't get into it.
Man.
I can do a test on that.
Got bums me out there better for the air.
I know.
Sure.
But environmentally there's a lot of concerns with those things like how they
extract them,
the minerals that they use to make them the batteries and the lithium.
Lithium comes from a a lot of like the comp conflict minerals that comes from a
lot of like really poor areas or people are forced to mind these things.
They have no other way to make money.
There had been a bunch of articles read all shits made pretty much cell phones
say that about everything.
Here's the thing is is cell phones like cell phones,
like cold Chan that they use to make sense?
Is that how you call it?
Cold Tan?
I think it's called Cold Tan is a mineral that they use to make cell phones and
for the longest time at least it was like a lot of it was being made in the
Congo and these people were essentially almost slaves like minus stuff.
These little children,
these child workers to mine this stuff.
Their stuff though Colton,
conflict minerals in the Congo,
there's documentary has been done on this.
It's horrible.
So in the Congo,
this is one place.
It's particularly rich with Colton and these poor,
poor,
poor people.
Like a level of poor that you and I just will never understand and we need that
for our phones.
Yup,
Yup.
It's a key ingredient in a cell phones and I think maybe laptops too,
but definitely cell phones.
It's fucked up,
dude.
You know?
It's just,
it's a weird thing,
man.
You got a phone,
right?
If you get a phone made by any of these major companies,
a lot of them get made in China jumping off the roof or are they just working?
What it,
what's going on right here?
They're getting paid.
They're getting paid very little money.
The thing is to us,
a compared to other people that have the standard pay out there,
right?
Maybe you don't.
Maybe they're happy to have a job.
They're probably the handing of themselves.
Like in China.
I don't know how to put up a net.
So many people are jumping on that were just sifting through the gravel,
Chilean headphones on listening to podcast.
People die doing it all the time.
Yeah.
They listening to like how stuff works.
Just K.
Dot.
Ted Talks on cold Tien,
like,
no,
this is not how it goes.
I'm shoes.
I mean knee deep in mud right now looking for this.
Let me call you back.
I'm on Facebook.
I'm going to Piss so bad.
Let's wrap this bitch up.
A Ebi is tomorrow.
Eddie Bravo.
Tell people how they can listen to an end.
Me,
it's going to be on UFC fight pass or you can order it on paper
view@inchbyinch.tv.
It's at the Orpheum.
So if you're anywhere in southern California,
get down there and watch it live.
It's a downtown La Gary Tone and Vagner Roach and Nathan Orchard.
Pj Bark,
Bill Cooper and a four man combat Jujitsu tournament.
Damn.
Featuring Richie Martinez.
Super High Level Jujitsu.
Uh,
but in to Shab.
What's going on with you?
I'm on tour in November,
December t.k.com for tickets.
Calusa Ohio.
I'm in buffalo and I'm all over Nashville.
Xannies damn all over man.
Congratulations.
That's awesome.
That's it.
Friends.
We're done for today.
See Ya.